at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by four Sigma deck
you might remember four sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if too much of a headache
don't worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it now give you my take quote
a warning for those in the experimental
mindset reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine so
if the bitterness is too much I
recommend trying it with honey
and or nutmilk such as almond milk and
quote so I'm gonna say no you should
suck it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
you should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
youngins when they say boo and I'm sure
they're cool which means you're not able
to eat bitterness bitter is in many
cases an indication of things that help
liver detoxification and so on
not saying that's the case here but I've
tested this reishi lecture on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and no don't put it in honey or nut milk
or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like puer that kind of stuff that
type of tea you're gonna dig it so just
try it okay
back at you then my read if you'd like
to naturally improve your sleep both on
set and quality I think naturally you
might just enjoy this ratio lecture
without any sweeteners it has organic
reishi extract organic fueled mint
extract organic rosehips extract organic
Tulsi extract and that's it no fancy
stuff no artificial whatchamacallit
anything so check it out go to four
sigma tech comm forward slash ferrous
and get 20% off this special batch I
don't know if they're gonna be making
much more of this since it was made
specifically for you guys so do me a
favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI g ma t IC comm /e
ferrous f e RR ISS and get 20% off the
special batch and you must use the code
a ferrous to receive your discount fer
AR ISS so again go to four sig Metacom
forward slash ferrous and then use code
ferrous for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I committed to making
sleep a top priority trying to fix onset
insomnia or continuing to fix that depth
of sleep quality of sleep I tracked a
lot I tested a lot and I revisited
really everything from the daily routine
to these surfaces I slept on playing
with a chili pad whatever and when I
moved to Austin I got all new beds
including mattresses from helix working
with the world's leading sleep expert
certainly some of them helix sleep
developed mattresses personalized to
your preferences and sleep style to make
sure that you can have the best sleep
possible without costing thousands upon
thousands of dollars helix sleep has
recently added a new layer to customize
sleep with the helix pillow the all new
pillows are fully adjustable so you can
achieve perfect comfort regardless of a
sleep position or body type or if you're
a shifty type like me I move around
quite a bit when I sleep just take their
simple two to three-minute sleep quiz to
get started and that will help ensure
that they can build a mattress or pillow
that you will love the mattress
whatever this bespoke mattress is that
you arrive at will get to you within a
week and the shipping is completely free
you can try the mattress for 100 nights
and if you're not completely happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund I tested that refund policy
because I test all of these sponsors and
kick the tires a lot we tested it and
they came through on making sure that we
got ultimately the right mattress for my
body type to personalize your sleep
experience visit helix sleep comm
forward slash Tim and you'll receive up
to 125 dollars off your mattress order
that's helix sleep a chi lis forward
slash Tim for up to $125 off your order
why hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show of escape noise
my beautiful little maid hid this show
as some of you may know is about
deconstructing world-class performers
teasing out the habits routines life
lessons thought processes frameworks and
so on from people in many different
industries many different areas of
expertise that you can hopefully apply
to your own lives and my guest today is
Steve Jurvetson who really has his hand
in many many different worlds you can
say hello to him on Twitter at dfj Steve
he is a venture capitalist but a lot
more than that focused on founder led
mission driven companies at the cutting
edge of disruptive technology now you
might think to yourself well that's what
I might hear many venture capitalists
say but he was recommended to me by a
past guest as a guest Matt Mullenweg who
I trust very implicitly and to give you
an idea of the street cred he has been
the founding venture capital investor in
four public companies and many rapidly
growing companies like Planet Memphis
meets mythic and Nirvana and er V
nirvana he also led investments in
startups that were later collectively
acquired for twelve billion dollars
probably much more at this point before
co-founding the firm DFJ draper fisher
german s'en steve was a R&D engineer at
hewlett-packard worked in product
marketing at Apple and next many many
stories about his mentors there and then
spent a short stint in management
consulting at Bain he completed his
electrical engineering degree at
Stanford in two and a half years think
about that for a second graduating
number one in his class and went on to
earn all sorts of degrees MS EE MBA etc
in 2016
President Barack Obama appointed Steve
as a presidential ambassador for global
entrepreneurship Steve was also chosen
as one of quote Tech's best venture
investors and quote by Forbes and as the
venture capitalist of the Year by
Deloitte Steve will be launching a brand
new venture fund sometime later this
year and you can read about it at future
dot ventures so not
calm but future dot ventures that's how
you would spell it out not surprisingly
he will be focusing on passionate
founders who are on a mission to make
the world a better place with a penchant
for unique ideas and disruptive
technologies and disruptive may be an
overused term but Steve really
understands what that means and we dig
into some very very very specific
examples that might make your mind
explode so without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with Steve Jurvetson Steve welcome to
the show thank you Here I am looking
here at all my notes and you were kind
enough to send links to various
resources interviews discussions and I
have to tell you I feel a little
overwhelmed because usually I have
someone on the show it's like all right
we have person a they're really good at
rock climbing I think we'll start with
rock climbing and in this case we're not
even going to cover ten percent of the
notes that I have in front of me and
they've already been winnowed down but
there is I think one story that I came
upon that I'd love for you to describe
for people just as a starting point and
it's a quote and then you can give the
background from Professor David Deutsch
out of Oxford and it begins with and
please correct me if I'm wrong the only
way this computer could be as powerful
as it is
dot dot dot what is this quote sure and
I may be paraphrasing because it's stuff
you wrote back in 2002 2001 at least I
read the book fabric of reality 2002 and
he's talking about the power of quantum
mechanics and the potential for quantum
computers and in so doing he and richard
fineman both realized that a quantum
computer to be fundamentally unlike
anything we have in this world today and
the way that quote roughly ends is that
the only way to explain the power of
these computers is to invoke the notion
that it is sort of engaging the
resources across parallel universes that
if you just use the resources at one
universe now there's so much you can do
but in this case you actually are in the
most poetic sense harnessing almost
refractive echoes across parallel
universes to do computation in a
a different way and that usually bends
the mind of most scientists and the even
physicists to the point of breaking or
looking the other way and the common
response to this is I don't understand
one bit of that and it had me captivated
so I want to jump into a number of areas
that I know nothing about or very little
about even though I might use the words
occasionally as people spend a lot of
time in Silicon Valley or want to do but
for people who don't have the background
I want to highlight a few things about
you or actually one just as we're
delving into some of the science so your
background or a lot of your background
is engineering correct so electrical
engineering that's right bachelors and
masters and started a PhD and you were
able to do so much of that partially
because you finished your undergrad in
two and a half years yes right okay the
point I want to make with that we're
going to come back to that because I
don't know how that even happens is that
you have technical literacy so so so I'm
all still learning like a child right so
can you walk us through one of the terms
I was hoping to understand for myself
and that is quantum computing what what
is a quantum computer right a quantum
computer is a device it's usually
something that is either cooled down to
almost absolute zero or has some other
phenomenon that it takes advantage of
that is at the edge of what is the known
universe meaning when you cool something
to zero behavior of materials changes
dramatically if you have a
superconductor the way it works is
dramatically different from normal
conductors and so what people have found
is that rather than look at quantum
mechanics as something that is spooky
and bizarre the way Albert Einstein even
described it this spooky action at a
distance this ability to entangle things
to have them to have their fates
intermingled can be not just used for
things like really unbreakable
cryptography and data transmission it
could also be used in a very bizarre way
to build a computer and this computer
looks something like a row of let's say
rings that are either magnetically in
one direction or the other you think of
it in a tradition of Peter it's a 1 or a
0 but actually it could be a everything
in between
simultaneously much like when you dive
into how an atom actually works there
isn't an electron any given point it's a
cloud it's a probability function around
the atom well that cloud is something
we're not used to in the real world
we're used to the statistical you know
aggregation of many atoms that's like
there's a table it's hard I can't put my
hand through the table it's not
sometimes here and sometimes over there
but the farther down you look the closer
and closer to let's say the atomic scale
you notice the behavior of physics
becomes quantum physics and rather than
being something spooky you can actually
harness this to compute in a very
peculiar way in a way that in a very in
a very simple level you could say it's
as if all of your memory bank in a
computer was a 1 and a 0 simultaneously
so you instantly jump or tunnel to the
answer you're looking for it to
particular problem so rather than
exhaustively searching millions or
billions or trillions of possibilities
to find let's say the key that unlocks a
digital lock you just jump to the answer
that's seemingly science fiction but
these these computers do exist yes um
and even within scientific communities
there's some backbiting that says well
wait do they really exist is this one an
example is that just a fast analog
computer so it is at the edge of a what
people believe is possible and I think
we're actually literally at this period
of history where these computers are
starting to come out I've been on the
board of directors of one for over 15
years now I suppose a little early I
think - is ready for prime time it's now
at the point where for example Google
says that their quantum computer that
they bought from company called d-wave
outperforms their and hated entire data
center on certain computational tasks
and that are important to what they do
and in other tasks that are meant to
really show how fast is it they found a
hundred million fold speed-up over the
best computer they could buy from anyone
else how big is such a quantum computer
it they're almost all about the same
size not because the computer is big but
because the cooling apparatus and the
shielding from an etic flux is high so
if you think about a refrigerator size
slightly bigger like two refrigerators
the actual computer is just on a little
silicon chip that's as small as any
other silicon chip it's just cool to
literally 500 times colder than the most
remote part of outer space I mean like a
few milli Kelvin above absolute zero
which is really cold so to put the speed
or power in perspective could you please
describe a graph that I've seen you
present
which I believe might start with is it
2002 right and it looks like it it
progresses up to the right almost out of
45-degree angle now that the angle is is
that important I mean depends on what's
on on the axis but could you describe
what these different what these points
the points represent it's something I've
affectionately called roses law and with
a sort of homage to Moore's law because
Moore's law is actually named by Carver
Mead it wasn't Gordon Moore himself who
labelled his law Moore's law and nor
didn't nor did Jordy Rose the founder of
d-wave but when I was first speaking
with him in 2002 having just read David
doshas book he had produced a single
qubit they're called qubits for like
quantum bits so I'll just use the
acronym qubit
he had manufactured one of these and
tested and characterized that and had
sent to the manufacturing facility that
was the qubit the entire computer they
think of it as by loose analogy like a
memory array it would be like a one bit
memory array got that's a really
powerful memory right so when you go
from one to two you see you're now able
to explore all possibilities of to the
second power so for memory states if you
have three qubits you could
simultaneously explore 8 possible memory
states you know for 16 and so forth
right it's a doubling so as you add a
single qubit you've roughly device with
some hand-waving doubled the power of
your computer roughly speaking on the
order of a two to the end phenomenon so
if you were to add one new qubit every
year which he just stated so coming to
like where did this graph come from he
just stayed in 2002 I think we're gonna
double the number of qubits in a
functional quantum computer every year
in perpetuity and so I had to ask is
that just because Gordon Moore said
something that sounds kind of similar
and that we had a conversation I don't
remember being particularly persuaded
other than it's a semiconductor process
it takes roughly here to digest the
prior generation yeah why shouldn't we
be able to do this and sure enough
that's held till today right so that's
been 16 years of doublings the way the
graph gets interesting though is as with
Moore's law it comes out of nowhere like
so Moore's law you could actually trace
back hundreds of years arguably that our
capacity to compute as a species has
been doubling roughly every year since
we started to compute since we had any
kind of abacus I mean like it's kind of
weird how this has been growing and the
semiconductor industry is just a modern
version of that on a quantum computer
that doubling starts to reach thresholds
where you can do things that you
couldn't do with any computer on
so on this graph he was if you look
forward and here's where there's been a
little bit of a time delay by the way
just a full disclosure where the power
some of these computers there's been a
bit of overhead there's been a bit of
you know setup and readout times there's
been a bit of noise and other things
that have made the power of it not it
still scales like the original curve
like that 43 degree angle you're
painting in people's minds but the power
that that represents is imagine you have
to go like a little maybe 2 or 4 times
bigger to hit some of these thresholds
but unless something falls off the rails
we will soon in like the next couple of
years have computers that can outperform
any computer on earth then you give it
another couple years and it would
outperform all computers that could ever
be built on earth even if you use the
entire matter of the earth to build them
and then this is where David Deutsch
started to run this thought process out
give it another couple years he would
outperform all computers that could
possibly be built if you use the entire
matter of the universe as at your
disposal to build in the best possible
computer any human could ever design and
you gave it the length of the universe
in time to work on a problem it still
couldn't solve these problems and the
quantum Kidder could and and in due
course like in less than an hour like
that's when if your head hasn't already
drilled out of your ears it just really
explodes like pulp and what there's
places where nature gives you a peek
into its wonders right and as a
scientist or engineer we get these and
almost any field of exploration whether
its inner space of quantum physics or
outer space in the frontiers of the
unknown and here's one of those examples
that just opens your eyes to how little
we know in that you'll sometimes see
this maybe in an experiment I give an
example of one that David Deutsch also
likes that some people might remember
from their high school physics if you
have two slits two very narrow slits and
you shine light through them you get
this diffraction pattern on a screen on
the following on the following side of
the table and that's always been
something we learned at the bulk
statistical physics of a lot of photons
a lot of light going and interfering
with each other these interference
patterns
well what's fascinating is if you send
single photons at a time they will shoot
through and if you just tally up the
statistics they'll end up creating a
distribution pattern just as if it were
many photons interacting so the own
expansion the wave theory of light is
that waves interact with each other and
that's what creates this pattern there's
ripple pattern on the other side but
there's no interaction when you're
single
single photon of the time it's not
interacting with anything other than its
sister photon in a parallel universe
right and David Deutsch is like well
that's obviously the explanation that
makes all of this work other than it
bends people's minds so the two schools
of thought are that's the answer or I
don't want to talk about it
what is David's background is he's a
physicist yes yeah wants to make sure
yes I know he knows a lot I got way more
than yes he's not a charlatan yeah yep
how do you even make sense of that I
mean in terms of considering the
implications because this isn't we're
not talking about thousands of years
away potentially I mean this is in the
relatively near term future what are the
implications of that so the key to
answering that question is what are
these computers good for right and
either good news or bad news depending
on your point of view is they're very
hard to program at least historically
speaking years would go by between major
advances in the software if you will the
algorithms that one can run on a quantum
computer and do anything useful right
there was something called Shor's
algorithm that came out a few years back
that said hey you can actually factor
integers meaning break the number 15
into its prime factors 3 times 5 is 15
so if I give you 15 tell me what the
prime factors are if the number is small
we can kind of work our way randomly
through it through either exhaustive
search or some heuristic but we don't
really have a mathematical way to get
the answer and a quantum computer now
can just give you the answer which it
turns out would break most of
cryptography any of these mathematical
symmetries are at the core of public key
crypto so that's kind of worrisome
what it's useful for beyond something
that the spooks should be interested in
is we literally also want a Renaissance
of software discovery so things are that
it really seemed to be coming to the top
of near-term opportunities our quantum
chemistry and deep learning or machine
learning both of which are very
interesting quantum chemistry is quite
simply predicting accurately what a
small molecule will do it turns out if
you use a normal computer and you try to
solve shortens our great Schrodinger's
equations and do like the at what's
called the bottoms up have initio model
like what does a water molecule do what
does aspirin do how does it behave you
can't actually model this it just
computationally grinds to a halt a
quantum computer could do this almost on
a one-to-one mapping so a quantum
computer of about the same complexity as
h2o and all of its electrons is about
the size of computer you need to model
it perfectly like
when does it freeze how does whatever
odds phase transitions all these weird
properties of water that we take for
granted that really don't come from the
physics right you learn this in
chemistry but you don't learn in physics
because the the math it's
computationally too complex more
interesting to me personally I mean by
the way I first invested in computing
for quantum chemistry that was the
reason I got excited about this is what
we build a design drugs more quickly
figure out let's like a give an example
let's say you have some new h1n1 virus
and you're trying to figure out how can
I design a molecule that would dock to
this virus at a particular place that
like if I could only attach they're
chemically I could kill it
well that's very hard to do very easy to
state very hard to solve so you can test
a drug but you can't ab initio just
design it out of scratch and that's what
these hopefully will be able to do soon
they rapidly accelerate drug design the
other area that has enormous lis wide
applicability is in deep learning and we
talk more about that field later but
generally speaking building little
brains that can learn something very
quickly and like let's say it's pattern
recognition or image recognition for any
number of applications and do that much
better so that's why perhaps it's not
surprising Google's been the primary
customer of quantum computers for the
last 10 years is they use deep learning
everywhere so we're gonna I'm sure get
to deep learning I shouldn't be so
confident I'll do my best to come back
to deep learning folks I'm not yet a
deep learner by clearly with all the
neural networks that's the same thing
basically alright so this is you want to
come back to that and great alright so
I'll put this anonymous on my mysterious
pad here but question that is
tangentially related but since you
mentioned entanglement this is something
that's become very interesting to me as
a non physicist of course my ability to
dig into it is is limited but I heard I
believe it was radial lab I could be
making that up but an episode of radio
lab where they talked about the some of
the experimental design and results of
using lasers to impact entangled
supposed to be atoms does that sound
right or not sure they may be some
people they can create what's called a
bose-einstein condensate with lasers in
a sense trapping
light in making it stop or are doing
really bizarre things yeah so they were
looking at entanglement across not just
distances within a room but I didn't I
think they sent in a loop at CERN yes 60
70 80 miles that's right and so I
started wondering to myself again as
like a professional amateur is not
terribly good at any one thing it's like
well wait a second if if if you were to
ask David do it she might just laugh
this off as a ridiculous question but if
the Big Bang Theory or if the Big Bang
happened as many people imagine it to
have happened or think of to have
happened is it possible that everything
that we can see here if y'all touch is
entangled like is is there the
possibility that everything is entangled
anyway that's a question that I think
about but I've never asked a physicist
I'm not sure not not in the well my gut
is not in the powerful way that the
quanta computer takes advantage of it
but there is the possibility of well
first off I mean just for those who
don't know the experiment you're
referring to they sent two entangled
photons down sort of opposing
fiber-optic rings and then when they
were far apart from each other like
miles apart from each other they would
observe one and notice that the other
resolved its state instantaneously at
the same time so in other words there's
this notion of quantum indeterminacy
that you don't know whether it's a 1 or
a 0 or somewhere until you look at it
the moment you look at it it changes the
state it's just really both strange and
and provocatively a provocative notion
of the quantum physics and literally if
you look at one of them over let's say
on the left field you know miles away
it'll instantaneously resolve the other
one as well as if they were a single
unit and in fact it's you can't have
like you can't imagine information
passing between them because it's faster
than the speed of light that this is
like it's at the exact same moment that
these things resolved oh how come I'm
gonna get out of my depth yeah so my
takeaway I think they may take away that
that fascinated me and maybe the
hopefully every listener is we are just
beginning to scratch the surface of
understanding what these phenomena are
about and taking advantage of them in in
a useful way
all right so usually quantum physicists
literally for you know since beginning
of the field have been more theoretical
than experimental more more theoretical
than useful you know it might you say
and I think the potential crashing of
this on to business Shores is
potentially upon us where again when we
talk about let's say the power of deep
learning if you could build an
artificial intelligence broadly defined
of any kind a simple one that plays
games or a simple one that recognizes
cancer in you know pathology slides or
recognizes anything in an x-ray and
medical imaging sense if you can do that
better than anyone else on earth that's
a business opportunity and that
capability might start to lend itself to
those who have the cutting edge of
computation and in the past anyone could
buy a computer and catch up with you
know someone who has another computer it
was a commodity I just will just go buy
some more computers myself but what if
the practitioners of this sort of field
are so esoteric and limited that there's
only a handful of companies that know
how to do powerful computing that's kind
of a worrisome feature potentially so
not to dedicate too much time to
worrisome features but what what do you
see as the most likely existential or
greatest existential risks to humans
animals people things on this planet
oh I think it's be very different for
humans animals and things let's talk
about yet yeah because I think there's
all kinds of things we can do to hurt
ourselves that nature won't have any
problem with March right along the
cockroach's to still be out there for
many years since my cockroach audience
is still very small we'll go with humans
they're incredible creatures they're you
know they're gonna last through a lot so
I worry about the way in which cultural
evolution is while it's progressing it's
not progressing fast enough and we as a
society are going through more rapid and
gut-wrenching change of various sorts
that we may or may not be a prepared to
handle so for example we may be in the
midst I would argue of a ever
accelerating rich-poor gap that
politicians and policy makers just don't
have their head around and could lead to
a future of abundance as Peter Diamandis
writes about where everything's great
because physical things are so
inexpensive that even the poorest of the
poor can live like kings of just a few
years prior but I think the the cultural
in a sense set up for this is not
necessarily right which is we don't have
a lot of people thinking about it
whether it's you
how will let's say 10 years now 20 years
now we provide for basic human needs
globally is it gonna be normal
capitalism and a democracy is that gonna
work just fine for everyone or will it
be some that are horribly left behind
and I think social unrest is something
that worries me more and more I guess
and it's the same way there are other
things I've been involved with a
non-profit looking for you know asteroid
defense you know that's an existential
threat of another kind that's easily
addressed I mean for you know less than
four hundred million dollars you could
take that one off the table so hopefully
that will happen pandemic flu or
bioterrorism pause for a second so take
it off the table by oh so somehow I'm
destroying me no the key is just
detecting them long before they hit her
it's so unlike the movies Armageddon or
deep impact you don't want to wait till
final approach to try to do anything
about it sounds like a good braking it
turns a bullet into a shotgun shells
like it's way too late
yeah what you want to do and it's
actually this is what's so interesting
is for the first time ever we can put
satellites up that have these infrared
sensors that can detect these objects at
great distances and track them and we
have enough computational power to from
a couple of em all from three
observation points model help the n-body
problem of what will the next hundred
years of this object's orbit look like
and will it hit earth at any point in
the next hundred years so that is a
computationally complex thing we can do
today so putting up one of those
satellites in a near Venus orbit looking
out to capture all the threats to earth
we could do today with less budget than
some museums have right and the key then
is when you see something that will hit
Earth let's say 50 years from now or 30
years now you just bump it all you have
to do is like give it the slightest
little Delta V today and all of its
orbits around the Sun by the time it
eventually intersects with earth it's in
a totally different place and we can
computationally no yeah just rear end it
by a tiny bit or hit it head-on by a
tiny bit and then you're right problem
solved Wow but you need time on your
side you know that it takes years for
that tiny nudge to accumulate enough
distance Delta that you miss something
as big as Earth
so I interrupted I think your segue to
bioterrorism yeah bioterrorism worried
me a lot post 9/11 because I realized
looking into it and from an investment
side you made that it's increasingly
becoming the case that a small number of
people in fact individual with let's say
a college education in this field could
build weapons of mass destruction it
used to take armies it used to take you
know despots and fascist leaders of
countries and resources
country's to wield a weapon of mass
destruction to building the clergy and
editing things like that yeah exactly so
you know synthesizing smallpox you know
weaponizing and doing something you know
injecting interleukin 4 gene which makes
it incredibly deadly in Mouse pox pox
virus has effect all organisms that get
to a certain concentration level on the
planet so ants deer or anything that
live in dense areas chicken pox develop
a unique pox virus for that thing it's
kind of Nature's Way of telling you
there's way too many of you people on
this planet either within the herd
they can be bioengineered like crazy and
this worried me because when I spoke to
people in various government agencies
who spend their time modeling and doing
Red Team simulations of bioterrorism
outbreaks their only answer at the time
was well we hope they wouldn't do this
like like just kind of like a leap of
faith that this is such a horrible thing
to wield that people would stop short in
at the time I they gave me no comfort
yeah and this time passes I'm actually
think there is an element of truth to
that it's not the kind of thing the
typical terrorist cell can get someone
fired up about which is there is a weird
thing even within the worst if whatever
when put in quote marks worst parts of
societal troublemakers if you will on
the planet where this isn't a place they
tend to go right flying a plane in a
building is more natural vector of
getting attention for your mission and
getting someone to volunteer for the
duty than saying I want to go kill a
bunch of innocent people you know with a
contagious agent it's kind of weird
cross product of how did you convince
yourself of that why am I worried about
it too okay yeah it's on my top three
list of worries yeah what are the others
um let's see what so the inequality
slash unrest bioterrorism mm oh shoot
what is my other one well climate change
of course oh my god climate change see
the thing about climate change is that
worries me is the things I didn't know
I'll give one example last week I
learned of a new thing that I really
didn't learn to worry about until last
week which is of all places out of NASA
Ames the former director it was telling
me they'd been doing these interesting
studies trying to figure out how can we
induce hibernation and mammals which for
interstellar travel would be great can
you have in the movies the humans
somehow I'll go into a hibernation mode
right they know and all the movies we
see and they were doing studies with
rats and they could actually get rats to
hibernate for two days at a time by
exposing the hydrogen sulfide and that
immediately led me to ask well wait why
has that adapt
why would we have this sort of latent
pathway that really doesn't seem useful
for anything that puts rats to sleep for
two days at a time and they would die it
was longer than that and it turned out
back
one of the major extinction events and
I'll try to be more concise here than I
might otherwise be there was a major we
had a we've planted two first it led to
major climate change and the polar ice
caps melted a greenhouse gas the
greenhouse effect in the pond with the
ice caps melting wasn't the sea level
levels rot rose that just affects
Bangladesh and Miami and yeah but
doesn't take out humanity if sea levels
rise the thing that could take out
humanity is that the ocean currents
start stopped going and part of that was
driven by fresh water or melt off the
poles so potentially long before the
poles are completely gone or perhaps
completely unrelated that temperature
change if the ocean stops circulating
you get this complete dead zones where
we're gonna depend on the circulation of
nutrients to survive and basically
purple and brown bacteria took over and
there are these hydrogen sulfide
bacteria so you'd have these waves
usually coupled up to two days at a time
of just literally lethal gases sweeping
across the landscape that the survivors
learn how to hibernate through it so in
a long-winded way the thing that both
was both interesting like maybe there's
a hint of how we can induce hibernation
and mammals like humans but also
reminder that we've had climate change
many times in this planet and really bad
things can happen that have nothing to
do with carbon or methane or all the
things we're focused on it could be the
hydrogen sulfide gas that kills us which
is the rotten smell of eggs you know
it's nasty stuff on the social and
recipes in just because I know there
many people out listening who will be
wondering this what do you see is the
preventative steps if any that can be
taken to mitigate that risk yeah so
first I was looking at like well does it
feel like it's self-correcting is it
self rectifying is there something
that's a natural governing feedback loop
a negative feedback loop that says well
the rich get richer is there something
that naturally makes that not continue
further and unfortunately there's a lot
of positive feedback loops not in the
not in the sort of normative sense but
in just the regulatory sense of it it
just there's a runaway thing right like
runaway climate change and that is you
can get
well first off in is every business
becomes an information business over
time like the when I what I mean by that
is if the basis of competition why is
company a winning over a company B is it
the way they process information is it a
software layer to their business that I
think is rippling through every part of
industry whether it's the aerospace
industry the automotive industry
agriculture right it's not oh he worked
harder he was an artisan in his field
that's why he's a better farmer or she
it's oh he's got better gene scripts
from Monsanto or whoever and like the
basis of competition Agriculture's moved
to information tech has every industry
goes that way those industries will
start to look more like you know where
do you see Google and Facebook a
winner-take-all kind of dynamic where
eat between firms you have very few
winners and within firms you have very
few winners so at every fractal scale
it's kind of like a winner-take-all
there's a few people within these firms
that garner most of the wealth and
there's a few companies that garner most
of wealth in each industry now that's
perhaps so that trend is somewhat
negative that technology takes over more
and more it innervates more and more of
the economy it subsumes or eats the
world if you will that I think will be a
side effect one other side effect that's
negative is people sometimes reject
modernity when they can't keep up like
you sometimes subscribe to a different
belief system not science and math is
the progress of after ur of humanity
it's like I'm gonna reject science I'm
gonna reject math and there's entire
countries that are taking this stance
which is scary because they'll fall
farther further behind perhaps with an
inability to catch up to modernity when
and if they choose to so that worries me
the only current negative feedback good
thing that prevents well from when
completely crazy is that luckily and I
think maybe understandably the
wealthiest tech entrepreneurs tend not
to live like rock stars and you know or
rap stars and in LA they tend to give
back and a simple explanation for me
having seen many of these people before
they made billions of dollars and after
is that if you've made billions of
dollars and let's say under five years
you don't tend to ascribe that to your
incredible hard work and that's superior
intelligence right it is a farce right
to hold on to the belief that I'm better
than others that's why I'm a billionaire
and so they give back like in droves
like incredible acts of philanthropy and
so right now the philanthropy governor
is the one thing I see that's at least a
positive that says well maybe this
actually will allow people like Gates
and others to take on multi-year quest
like eradicating malaria or polio right
now polio and next malaria in a way the
government's can't even take on right
you have projects that exceed the budget
of the GDP of Nations you have projects
that exceed the lifespan of any
politician and luckily this is what
these people are choosing to do rather
than just show off right and so I'm
really happy about that um don't try to
live my life that way as well so the
question of going forward is there's a
lot of debates about basic income
universal basic income and experiments
that are trying to get funded to see if
it works the way people think it might I
think there could be all kinds of
experiments in almost corporate health
plans writ large so right now most
companies the more than a thousand
employees will manage the health plan of
the employees it's cheaper than going to
a third party like I will actually pay
for your health care because me paying
some third party you know they're just
making money off that and I've got
enough critical mass of other thousand
employees that that make sense
well imagine food shelter clothing and
health care are all equally cheap
meaning everything costs a dollar a
pound in the world that's a physical
thing that's that's what we're heading
in the end point all physical things
should be the same cost bag of potatoes
dollar pound bag of chips dollar pounds
why because um and then what you'll pay
for is the software the intellectual
property the thing that that in certain
places could lock up the miaow maybe
that Ferrari cost more because it's the
design not the materials but it's just
manufacturing methods are all converging
whether you think of it as additive
manufacturing or just traditional
manufacturing that stuff is not the rare
commodity you pay for intellectual
content like entertainment and software
it's like that's what all future
economies will based on and physical
stuff is all about the same what are the
means of manufacture well it's all going
to grow things I think increasingly in
the future I think we're gonna grow with
algae and other things chemicals like so
we think much sheer you know metric tons
of stuff you know liquid chemicals is a
big part of it and we got all almost all
that 90 plus percent from oil today and
the petrochemical economy it's all going
to shift to renewables and so that sort
of manufacturing stuff like the stuff
that goes into plastics which is more
and more of the physical world that
we're in obviously metals will still
come from you know unfortunately metal
sources but um I think will shift to
carbon and other kinds of materials
increasingly for structural stuff this
is potentially in the nanotech slash
carbon economy the future that you know
building things out of carbon
tube like structures and meshes is just
much lighter material sort of effective
and just efficient way of doing things
so we can look to nature and how does a
spider silk thread outperform almost any
other modern material like why there are
startups that are building synthetic
silk now with these old nano machines
that we produced what the spinner net
doesn't a spider so across it but coming
back to just this inequality point in
the corporate path potentially there or
it could be like a Peace Corps
equivalent that says you know if you
work for X number of years you get
healthcare in theory for a longer period
of time right and why couldn't that
start to subsume the way some companies
already provide lunch for free oh I
couldn't in a sense basic food shelter
clothing and health care be provided for
free and the healthcare part by the way
right now is a huge part of the economy
but it shouldn't be right I think we're
also and this is something I want to
invest in we're gonna find a way to make
the information search of health free so
we don't have to pay for the diagnosis
like and I can't imagine a future where
knowing what I need to do to make myself
healthy would be something I'd pay for
the actual doing if it involves surgery
maybe the pills they should all be a
dollar pound the physical thing and that
future I think will be incredibly
enabling for changing a society to a
stable one where you don't fear for the
healthier children or their ability to
live then you could have almost like a
Renaissance where you pursue the things
that are meaningful to you whether it's
poetry or science or what-have-you
meaningful work online people do this
all the time we spend a ridiculous
amount of our time on things that aren't
paid right but are meaningful to us and
that thing increasingly is what the
world will look like in the future
meaningful work and contributions not a
job in the traditional sense if the
pills are a dollar pound is the how do
you maintain the ability to develop and
innovate those drugs is just because the
computational power becomes so
inexpensive that you have then
competitors to the current incumbents or
of course high agencies to protect
exactly it's the long run because you
could imagine any well any current phase
or even long term and whether you call
it transition phase or just this is how
the new ones come to market is you have
to reward of course that effort to the
extent that effort is still as expensive
as it is today
you would you need to recoup it right
and that would be a notional property
question sort of the it's almost again
like the software but the generic
manufacturers know how to make the drug
it's but-for law around intellectual
property that it costs more so the
physical manufacturing is still going to
be a dollar found now the question is is
it priced as such and so in my model of
of this you'd start with the generics
and and have this massive distribution
channel like if you want to reach a
billion people you know you could sign
onto this platform for the you know the
poorest of the poor and reach a billion
people and some sort of you know
reasonable cost position for a generic
but I think the cost of discovery will
also come down back to the computational
and quantum chemistry side so that it
doesn't need to take so long and be so
expensive and right now you have an FDA
regulatory system that's a bit archaic
in that regard where they aren't quite
set up yet and they're trying to
transition but they're slow with this
into a world where you have personalized
medicine in a world where my medicine is
different than yours and therefore the
clinical trial concept really changes
right so we've been talking mostly
current RS a present and future tense I
want to go back to that two and a half
years oh sure
undergrad how does how does such a thing
happen well I mean how is that possible
it's interesting I took it as a
challenge when I started um at college I
was going to Stanford and I realized it
was expensive and my folks are
immigrants from Estonia and I kind of
found it difficult and we were
middle-class people at the time so I
didn't get financial aid and I was
looking at this I'm like you know this
costs a lot I just felt guilt so I
looked at the various rules for
graduation and it felt like a simple
system of equations like this Plus that
has to equal this you're like I actually
boil it down to oh I see they're just
trying to get four years of tuition out
of you so where can I explore the corner
cases and so I came in with the maximal
number AP credit so it actually goes
back to my high school st. marks in
Dallas that incredibly well prepared me
for college so I took the maximum number
of AP units that I could but of course
the universities limit not surprisingly
how much that applies I also took a
couple of summer classes that I could
transfer in from another school they
have a certain number you could do I max
that out one summer I was doing summer
jobs at HPS it's a night classes but
most of all I got learned a trick from
the grad students this is the key answer
actually by the time you get to be a
grad student you realize that you're
limited to
nine units a quarter and that's kind of
limiting if you take five minute classes
well shoot you know he'd take a class
and a half so what they realized is you
can sign up for a class for Less units
then it's listed just not more so the
checksum on the computer algorithm was
not did you say it's a five unit class
and or say it's six and it's only five
it's you know is it that or less so you
can just say it's a even a zero unit
class or one you can make it whatever
you want so you got taking more than
twenty minutes a quarter so you meet
that algorithm yet you've got all the
prerequisite classes you needed for the
next one you have the you have to map
this out early on right you have to
start freshman year to make this work
oh and I had to get a physics teacher to
let me take it class and a EE teacher as
sort of a against the prereqs in the
saying look I really can do this let me
let me try to take your class a year
earlier than I should so I could get the
prefect chain going so all these
simultaneous equations you have to solve
but the signing up for more classes was
the key there was like one winter
quarter where I took the equivalent
eight classes or you'd normally take a
load of four that made that possible
so when did if it did when did the
budgeting stop being a concern because
you then went on to continue your school
write it all flipped completely the
total mode shift when I started my
master's program and I became a research
assistant and cuz that paid for school
to the Mosin HP as well as looking
summer I started a master's in let's go
engineering right so still at Stanford
and I see that was a research assistant
professor Hennessy who when I went on to
do amazing things there and was an
entrepreneur himself at one point and
and I shifted gears I didn't want to
leave school I mean like going through
two and half years the problem is wow I
kind of missed out on a lot of social
life it's like living and so I basically
at that point stretched it out and tried
to stay as long as I could
you got a balloon payment it's kind of
funny how exchange yeah now I want to
stay I don't want to leave right and I
found a way to be in the freshman dorms
as a grad student which is awesome as a
computer coordinator there which meant I
kept the computers running and kept the
paper and the printers and but meant I
could have heard of freshman dorm life
all over again as I guys did and it was
fun so if we look then at your masters
and I suppose it would have been maybe
it was simultaneous but I pour after you
could tell us the MBA that came later
yeah I came later so the
ei why did you decide to get an MBA and
if would you do it again if why or why
not a lot of folks who I knew and no
arrests on same question and I think
it's I think it's a challenge a lot of
higher ed is facing which is is this a
vocational thing is this in one unusual
thing about business school it's the
only educational program I know of where
everyone comes in with prior work
experience you know even law school in
med school and what have you you know
you just go straight in from under there
right so it's got a very different kind
of feel to it that way and then people
might ask especially when there's a good
calm boom going on in the 90s do I want
to step out for a couple of years from
the economy and miss maybe that window
that opportunity that might be so ripe
so the main reason I went is networking
really to expand the sort of and to
learn frankly to weeks but the
networking came first to mind to meet a
bunch of people who have come from all
kinds of different backgrounds that I
could learn from not only at school but
throughout my life and one of the sub
points on that is for example pretty
basic questions like what do I want to
do in my life I bounced around from you
know engineering to management
consulting prior to business school and
thought well from what I know today
maybe I want to go to product marketing
I thought that's what I want to do but I
don't know I don't know anyone has done
that they know and well if I go to
business school I mean no matter where I
explain you know when I look there's
gonna be plenty of students who've done
that in the past they're looking to do
something new and so you get all you
have all the consultants to leave
consulting you know I bankers trying to
leave eye-banging and learn about
something new what better place and then
especially their employer hoping to
leave is paying for it exactly so that's
exactly right in fact that's exactly
what happened to me I was financed by my
former employer so I had that sort of
safety net and then when I decided not
to go back I had to pay for all my
tuition wow that was a it's a loan and
rightly so
yeah I didn't expect to get a free ride
and not go back but um but it did raise
a barrier to leaving um oh the other
thing is learning I mean I should go I
mean the business was not what I went to
learn per se I knew there'd be some
classes about business that I thought
would be helpful but I'd done so much at
Bain that I kinda had a small business
degree already and I taken the classes
back when I was under
a grad student prior in accounting and
finance so I had really taken a lot of
again the core courses I placed out of
every core course at business school -
and went right into the sort of the
electives and the more interesting
classes but I also knew that it was an
opportunity to take classes in other
departments you know to brush up on
actually molecular simulation of all
things and one of the classes I took was
on modeling you know quantum mechanical
properties of materials like like you
normally don't have take it take a class
like that um and and that really all
played out so it gave me so did it do
what I expected in a way it did I didn't
know venture capital existed right when
I grew up in Texas I'd heard the term I
never met a venture capitalist never
knew anything about him didn't wouldn't
know how to reach one no idea right that
man I grew up there wasn't the internet
so I literally would not know how to
reach one they're not in the phone book
there's no way to find them they really
aren't putting up billboards or
advertising in any way so um the entire
transition the venture occurred because
of people I met there and good point a
good location for it - that's - in the
middle of Silicon Valley that's Jo yeah
and then that was the only school I
applied to by the way if you think about
do you wanna go to business school I did
not apply to any other school because
there was no other school that would
have met that goal right so and also I
learned a lot and the network back to
the network almost every investment I
made I think it was almost for the first
year or two out of business gold and
that was a lot because it's middle of
the dot-com boom for me had some
business old connection it was either
literally entrepreneurs were from
business school or it was sent to me by
a professor from that business school or
like moving for the first year that's
how I jump-started everything I did in
sue my madness / method is usually not
chronological so really we're gonna zoom
out a little bit
what mistakes do you see otherwise very
smart venture capitalists making are
there any patterns are there any
particular types of mistakes could be
investors broadly speaking yeah oh my
god
tons yeah all over the place and and and
to be fair I'll try to drop in and
mention when I made those same mistakes
so I know means them I'm trying to judge
as if I know better
um but to to jump to mind one is way too
many seem to be a loss avoidant or
fearful and I'll kind of all elaborate
that in a moment and then but the other
one that jumps to mind equal
um they think they've hit upon the only
formula for success and yeah that has
many different levels at which that's
worried something so the first one um
this notion that of being fear driven I
have come across so many investors who
will say something like what we have a
strategy try not to try not to lose any
company as if that's like we're in the
trenches you know every company will
succeed and if you've just been at this
game for a few decades you'll realize
that's just folly right the the earlier
you go the higher your death rates gonna
be a startup so the majority will fail
just give them time and that's sad
reality took a while to sink in for some
but until it does you're gonna be very
timid in your investing so most
investors I see just let all the biggest
homeruns pass them by almost every term
sheet I've written to a company that's
turned out to be a spectacular home run
I had no competition at the time of the
series it was kidding like nobody else
would invest in the company what would
the reasons for not invest up oh yeah
it's crazy it's way too early it's a
science project no trial
yeah there's no product I mean so first
off almost everything I'm doing there's
no product no customer yet it's an idea
it's in prototype stage of a development
or there's no even prototype yet or they
just don't agree the world is gonna
change in this way so and in often cases
conventional wisdom would support their
point of view like let's not invest in
any automotive company because every
investment since Henry Ford has failed
like a hundred percent of them they were
just I mean scattered on the highway and
there's been village by the way many
many startups funded well over ten
million dollars you know so if I came
back you know decades ago that's a lot
of money I'll the automotive sector all
of which afield many and batteries many
and solar I mean just just scores I mean
maybe hundreds of companies have failed
so when you've let's say lost four times
in a row you just give up on the
category so sometimes it's the more
experienced Korres all the Bester's like
well that whole sector I'm just gonna
like steer clear because I have too many
scar tissues neither um but but that's
not really the thing I'm time I think
about you know new entrants to the
venture business people who you would
think we'll take a strategy of
differentiating myself from my peers and
abate like like having a basic strategy
let's say they say why wouldn't I want
to work with me versus all the other
firms and if it's like well I'm
investing in the hot sector pick
whatever it is did you or you know
consumer internet or social this or you
know
watching that it's like well it's the
hot thing well yeah but this also 100
other people had the exact same idea
used it's the hot thing like why are you
different and there's like no answer so
um this this lack of strategic thinking
about a and also like a thinking of a
long-term strategy like okay whatever
you're doing today is that gonna work
ten years from now whatever that
strategy is and like I don't care
strategy from anyone like okay here's
how I'm gonna stand out over a sustained
period of time here's how I will you
know either it could be simple things
like I'll have an itch I will only do
XYZ and I'll be known for my niche or my
specialty what worked for you and their
elite is when you're just getting
started it was um well first it was a
stroke of great luck which is the
dot-com boom as we now call it you know
was just starting to happen and I was
ready for that and open-minded enough so
I didn't have the scar tissue which is
by the way scar tissue for traditional
investors was if you invest in anything
that was like entertainment or media or
shrink-wrap software as they called it
which is low price software for
consumers that would be the consumer
software segment but it was just a
horrible play some games hits driven
business it still is a horrible segment
is to do non internet consumer price
point stuff it just it's a Death Zone so
they thought the internet was that they
didn't realize it's an entirely
different business model the whole what
we now know around cloud computing
around subscription services around
viral marketing its potential none of
this was known at the beginning and if
you put it into a prior bucket it would
be all those are bad sectors so
unbelievably one of the biggest
investment opportunities probably the
venture industry has ever seen was
largely avoided by most venture capital
firms and when I started in 1995 we did
about a third of all internet investing
industry-wide Wow like the entire
venture industry and that quickly
changed in say d6 87 and excuse me 96 97
and when Netscape at its IPO boom
everything changed because the MAL there
was an example of a winner this pattern
will come again in space investing and
everything soon as you have a single
winner then the sheep phenomenon and the
herd mentality kicks in right so you
know scores appeal and then investing in
a sector after it's had his first win so
to your question being under the
tutelage of Tim Draper to say hey
actually let's try to think big I mean I
credit him for being my mentor into the
industry to say not let's think about it
the way bankers do
let's not be fearful let's ask the
entrepreneur how they're under
estimating the market size right to
think how much bigger might this
opportunity be then even the people
pitching it or imagining that's a
thought experiment I often like to go
through and there'll be times when
occasional not often where I'll be like
wow you are so under selling your
opportunity cuz normally I run or trying
to sell to the maximum extent possible
to predict the largest possible
addressable market to think well phase
one of my business I do this then phase
two I take over the world in some way
right then to actually try to push them
further yeah and then want to invest in
them you know is an interesting adjunct
because then they you know you're on the
same page so I so I credit Tim Draper I
could at the internet and then most
importantly is there's a there was a
simple rule I started implementing and I
don't remember when it started it just
seemed like the natural thing to do
around early stage investing so when I
thought about this is like okay
most things fail if they win they've
gotta be huge okay check they should
change the world they should be
disruptive you know those are words
people use well how would I know if
something really is big and disruptive
like Oh
everyone everyone entrepreneur claims it
right like you'd be doing a payment
processing thing for back in whatever
you know payroll systems like we're
gonna change the world of payroll right
okay what really is gonna make an
enormous opportunity is it seemed to me
that a they're describing an enormous
market but B here's the killer no one
else has done it before
like instill the simple real-life use of
thought my entire career investing is I
want invest in things that are unlike
anything I've seen before and there's
all kinds of correlations to come out of
that the first is yeah you're investing
in some unusual things like d-wave you
know back in 2002 there were no other
quantum computer startups zero on the
planet Earth there was not a single
company claiming to build a quantum
computer big or small
actually for about five years afterwards
as well so that was like the most
extreme like when maybe for good reasons
no one was doing it back then when
hotmail first came there's nothing like
it that we'd seen when I first divested
in Skype there was anything quite like
that the the way they did peer-to-peer
voice over IP and similarly with Tesla
and electric vehicles and I can get into
why that one maybe is the most corner
case of whoa wait there a lot electric
car startups why is that one special we
can talk about it but certainly SpaceX
you know would qualify as well as unique
ideas at the time in the startup domain
and but the benefit for my career was it
has me perpetually searching for the
next great technology wave so
just when the dot-com boom was getting
to its fevered pitch I wasn't smart
enough I know that this is a kid I
wasn't that smart enough to predict a
crash I know that I wasn't because I was
contributing in writings and other
things at that time saying oh the boom
is just starting it's gonna go up up up
up right I believed that I just wanted
to but it's gonna keep going another we
wouldn't have a look at correction but
on the other hand I was not finding
anything unique I saw for business plans
for selling pantyhose on the web all
we're gonna do guzel dot-com got
venture-backed like like three others
like really like for business plans to
sell pantyhose or just balls comment
like God what is just balls do oh yeah
just balls venture-backed just sells
balls the name was awesome we got just
balls I come what do we sell balls you
want a bat no you want a glove know we
got balls balls of all kind small balls
big balls
golf balls tennis balls wait a second we
have a founder
no okay making sure but this shows you
how absurd it got to say take the
economy and like the internet changes
everything we're gonna like divide up
the economy in weird ways that hasn't
divided up before and make that a
business like that's what I knew this is
crazy and I started investing in
nanotechnology like total left field
shift and there's a reason I picked that
particular sector but the important
point is I didn't keep investing in the
internet companies long past their prime
not because I was smart on when the
correction would come because they
weren't unique anymore there's like
every viral marketing idea that I at the
time that I could find had come now to
money so I avoided a lot of pain we look
we but if you add up every internet
remember we did so many of them if you
had of every Internet company we
invested in that lost money add them all
up it was less than single deals lost
from other firms like buy calm lost more
money than everything we've ever done
combined because we didn't load up the
boats or a drinker and kool-aid too deep
in any one of them and we were every one
of them was unique so there wasn't like
this sector riscos did you get
diversification for free where I
definition you're diversifying your
portfolio and it had me move it and has
me throughout my career always on the
lookout to learn something new knowing
that I'm gonna have to hop to new sektor
not saying I wanna spend my whole life
as a semiconductor investor or as a
consumer software investor because that
is so limiting you know right that might
have a good tenure run yep but if you're
not continually learning something new
at the edges pivoting from the edges of
what you ready no to something slightly
different right you're gonna be
constantly why did you choose no
technology that was a bit of a mistake
but it was a mistake in retrospect but
it's the only thing I felt I
differentially knew better than others
it was harkening back to which was which
fortunately wasn't that many years prior
that had been studying some really hard
technologies like molecular modeling and
chip design added some chip design at
Hewlett Packard so I had enough as I
looked at the mentor landscape
differential knowledge error to say well
there's something I could harken back to
it's not the internet because the
Internet anyone could do at this point
right then the angel has to the flooding
and like you know every banker
consultants flooding it's like the
landscape littered with capital and
people investing in that sector well
there's nothing wrong on a nanotech I
had been exploring at the foresight
Institute a number of others sort of
think tank like conferences that the
radical potential has had to
revolutionize a bunch of things and the
one part that I think was indicative of
what's to come later in my career it was
not really in any way an industry it
isn't a sector it doesn't describe a
company there's no such thing as a
nanotech company unless you're building
tools to service that industry you know
in a weird way manufacturing equipment
maybe but not any attractive sectors it
more was a set of Science and Technology
capabilities that would strive across
many industries so even today there'll
be companies that I'll meet with and
things that were unique in that from
that era will play out like well the
value of simulation on any molecular
system like well how good is your
simulation on any physical thing you're
building in general these questions are
process questions like how do you do
innovation how do you do
entrepreneurship that carries through
but that platform technology which just
tell you what I'm what I mean by this
nanotech was like a platform applied in
many areas have new ways of doing
material science if you will then
there's this whole field of synthetic
biology like if you can manipulate DNA
with CRISPR or other technologies what
are all the things you could do with
that capability and it's very broad it's
not just health and food and then more
recently deep learning neural networks
what we Mike's describe is narrow AI
that whole field is widely applicable I
think every company will use it
eventually so again we can come to that
later but that's like a platform that's
not the other shirt today there are some
quote machine learning companies all I
do is stuff related machine learning but
much more interesting is all the
industries that will be change
by the use of machine learning in
vertical industries and so you know to
put a cap on it nanotech you know if you
look think look back at it today well
know there's an announcing industry it
would be like saying well where's the
thermodynamics industry well [ __ ] you
know there isn't one right little bit
sort of is like thermodynamics as a
concept you know there was a time when
actually companies named themselves
thermo electron and and you know her
medics or all these ones that it's just
now subsumed into the fabric of Science
and Engineering so as a geek I've always
been fascinated are there see changes in
basically how we do science and
engineering
maybe that's the simplest way of saying
it and I think today deep learning is
the best example that a fundamentally
different way of doing engineering so
that more time for a friend of mine so I
think deep learning or let me just call
it machine learning broadly this is a
bunch of sub branches this is everything
from generative design in in in sort of
the Autodesk CAD CAM SATs it's you know
it's it's studying stellar Tom Adele the
way Steve Wolfram does its genetic
protein cell automata
these are simple little simple little
mathematical constructs that just says
if you're gonna draw oh my god you're
probably want to edit this out of the
final thing is it's it's may not relate
to anything other than its create this
book a new kind of science and it really
a series of epiphanies for Wolfram and
others that that the world is really
interesting when you look at iterative
algorithms applied millions and billions
of times so solar trauma day is just
imagine you start with a random dot or
two in the moment like automaton but
with yeah sort of unveil so you have
this little simple rule almost like the
Turing machine that says I'm just gonna
go left to right and look at the dots
above me and if the dot above me I'll
look at the three dots above me one
directly above me left and to the right
and based on all possibilities of those
three dots which is you know to the
third power possibilities I'll have
either a dot or not a dot here and so
you would think that such a simple rule
that just says look at the three dots
and and and there's literally only
sixteen possible things that I'm gonna
you know conditions that I could be
seeing up there um I'll have some other
you know I'll do some something in most
cases it's very boring it's just like
the whole thing's black or it's got like
the nice you know pattern of triangles
but in a few cases like rule 31 it
unpacks into this incredible complexity
that is not repeating
there's no way to jump to let's say that
40th or the 50th 100th layer of this
unfolding you have to run the experiment
and the reason I find this so
philosophically interesting is this is
the same thing in evolution it's the
same thing in neural networks is the
same thing and all these new engineering
modalities where you can't
mathematically get a shortcut to the
answer you actually have to just run
this little algorithm oh no no nor again
so you can't like for example you can't
reverse evolve you can't figure out
where do we come from in any direct way
it sort of lost you can run the tape
forward but you can't run it backwards
you can't do a mathematical shortcut
across it and so an example of why this
as a thought experiment is important is
whenever you're developing these neural
networks whenever you're training let's
say these little AI so and I think this
is the path soup AI in general so it's
important like this is how it works you
can't understand the thing you've made
nor can you predict as you train them
further and further what you're going to
get there's a bit of discovery emergence
if you will it's kind of like raising a
teenager or parenting more than it is
programming you can learn about the
process of creation like I know how to
make a teenager but I can't tell you
exactly how it all works right and I
certainly can't go in there after I'm
done and tweak a few neurons to make
them smarter or french-speaking or
whatever is like no that's a really
weird artifact that works really
powerfully but it's not purposeful
design it doesn't do what I tell it to
do exactly it can learn to do what I
trained it to do but you know with some
edge cases it's a little out of control
and that's what I think the eyes of the
future will look like so I I can come
back to it if you want to talk about AI
and deep learning but I just
you asked about cellar Tomita and the
process learning the key with this
question started with this engineering
right yeah so think I want to I that I
wanted to say is I think deep learning /
machine intelligence is the biggest
advance in how we can do engineering
so specifically engineering since the
scientific method itself so can you wait
actually an engineering might been
random like I think astrologist you well
I think this is true and then you have a
scientific method you leased a method of
compounding knowledge over time this is
a different way of innocence growing
solutions to problems instead of
purposely designing them but you can
build things that exceed human
understanding we're doing this all over
the place in molecular engineering in
software design in in a variety of
fields we have sort of reached the limit
in many cases of what a human any human
or even
humans can put their heads together and
design and now we can push way past that
and build things beyond our own
understanding
she's pretty powerful yeah could you
define just revisit you might have
already done it indirectly but the deep
learning and neural networks yeah I
guess I have sort of an approximate
equal sign here I'm not sure if they're
synonymous in the 80s they involve
neural networks and deep learning
there's a reason the word deep came in
well first you want a new name when
something kind of came and went let's
pass a you know a couple decades ago
look as I studied neural network second
the eighties um you know like to give it
a new moniker but there is a reason deep
in the sense of more layers so what do
they have in common so and in fact in
all networks I think it could be a more
generic term for all this it's inspired
by the brain it's a way of simulating a
brain like mmm subset so not the whole
brain but imagine Li you were to take a
little tiny chunk of your brain a
cortical column or some area and say
well what's really going on well you
have cells that connect to a bunch of
others in our brain it's usually a fan
out of a thousand or so to ten thousand
connections from each one so a huge fan
out
each cell connects to a bunch of others
and when one fires it or goes down the
dendrite and their little synapse fires
and it triggers another one we all have
some vague sense of okay neurons are in
our brain and they and they sort of
wired together and they fire together so
now if you want to simulate one of those
in a very simplistic way in a way that
you like imagine the programmers back in
the 80s and I had pretty not very
powerful computers well how could you
make a computer like brain well we need
all that complexity but we don't need
all the details of ion channels and
synapses and and all the
neurotransmitter chemicals that are an
artifact of our biology what really is
the essence of what's going on here and
the essence is something activates it
fires it's connected in a network to
some others and if there's enough you
know inputs that are firing and beyond a
threshold then then downstream neuronal
fire too so the simple idea is if I to
recap is neurons fire they're wired to
other ones you sum up all your inputs
like everything that's connected on the
input there's like thousands of inputs
and if it crosses some threshold then
you fire that's it and then then you
just layer on tons of these and so the
deep learning is having more and more of
these layers instead of just like one or
two or three layers having scores of
these layers and a variety of other
algorithmic advances but really the
biggest breakthrough is
has been that we have a lot of data
today that we didn't have back in the
80s from the internet from Mechanical
Turk you name it all kinds of data sets
to Train on like if you wanted pictures
of cats with the label that's a cat
that's a dog I mean that's obvious today
we take it for granted like of course
you want a million of those you want a
billion how many pictures of castellón
right in the 80s good luck you could
spend your whole career trying to get a
good data set to train these neural
networks with plus we did have digital
cameras it means like it's crazy if you
think how little data we had ladies okay
so data is the first the other is GPUs
from Nvidia they started about ten years
ago as a side project in scientific
computing realized GPUs graphics right
so any gamer would be like I want the
latest to play my video games to do all
these polygons renderings offloaded from
your main computing chip the Intel chip
usually off on this side what used to be
a peripheral processor a coprocessor an
afterthought if you will that only
gamers cared about if you wear a
business computing user eat it in the
old days in the 90s you didn't care
about your GPU right you only cared
about was your CPU the thing that
computes your Excel spreadsheet or
whatever your database but the GPU
people are like pushing a whole
different kind of computational math
forward which was a lot of math like a
lot of polygons the more polygons the
more you know sort of you know
resolution you have in your game and so
an averaging way with a different
objective function not do a program that
a human wrote faster and faster but take
the same damn simple math of basically
it turned out to be made what's called
matrix multiply and add you know
multiply a whole bunch of numbers
together and add them up multiply add
them up it's like that core multiple
sort of mathematical operation the more
you could do the better your graphics
were and so they had an economic
incentive to really push the envelope
where if you asked let's say in the 80s
or 90s what else could that be used for
it the answer was well nothing right
that that's just does graphics it is
like totally optimized for rendering
graphics right but somewhere along the
way people realized wait a second
there's other areas in the scientific
computing world but by this I mean let's
say modeling the weather you know
modeling huh you know nuclear explosions
occur in government labs where they're
like you know we do a lot of that matrix
multiplying ad - can we try to see if we
could use it and so it was like a
skunkworks project management had no
resources against this I knew actually
one of the first four customers working
on this in R&D area of all things to
model how neurons fire
aw hell neuron actually follow biology
of a neuron down to as much detail as
possible company called evolve machines
and they were using GPUs and I and I
remember years ago saying we you just
bought for two thousand dollars at the
local we caught those fries yeah it
looked fries electronic store you just
bought more power than any supercomputer
of just two years ago for two thousand
dollars because of this domain right so
this incredible computer resource was
pushed to the limits from gaming and I
think almost poetically when you think
about rendering three-dimensional worlds
and making the photorealistic
you're doing something our brain does
exquisitely well right we get and have a
lunch of information on our retina in
our cortex and we down scale that to
image recognition building over there
your face the symmetry of your eyes I in
much like a neural network when you
train them it recapitulates our biology
it builds edge detectors and then
symmetry detectors and then I face
things and you can probe what's been
built a little bit and get a sense um I
got it just recapitulated the sensory
cortex in an artificial system that's
when the recapitulated meaning effect
recreated from scratch is an analog
sorry because you're just training it
like a baby gets born right opens its
eyes starts learning right right that's
the same general thing going on with
these neural networks the fact that it
has similar layers and his visual system
as our babies do it's just like that's
when people like me like oh my god this
is incredible right so back to the GPU
thing what I think's poetic is that
something that in a sense is meant to be
as realistic as possible to our vision
system has the kind of computational
systems we need to in fact do vision
systems in like oh let's do let's
recognize cats on internet or let's
recognize cancer in a you know pathology
slide that those general constructs
occur because our brain has evolved to
do data reduction and pattern
recognition in the world in a way that
is optimal for what we do so that when
we build these neural networks what are
they really good at all the same stuff
like and so all the applications there
and like speech processing visual
processing which is the simple stuff the
edge of our cortex and then naturally
it's going to start moving into
emotional systems and the frontal lobe
and the rest of our cortical systems and
so that's why I think it's the obvious
path to AI in the in the broadest sense
so many questions the I love that story
for where that story slash explanation
for a number of reasons one is how
careful one should be with dismissing
certain fields or even if they seem
trivial or a way to be a waste of time
like gaming right if you look at the
byproduct of the incentives that drove
that and then the off-label uses of GPUs
our GPUs I mistaken in thinking that
they also have a role in cryptocurrency
mining well absolutely right so the the
that's a very computationally intense
task and so it moved definitely from
Intel like CPUs to GPUs but they don't
even went further then I went to these
field programmable gate aways and then
the custom chips design from scratch
sort of it quickly went down that path
and deep learning chips will as well
there that's was one of my investment
themes our last three years as the deep
learning is doing the exact same thing
to custom chips she mentioned something
much earlier oh one last thing on this
oh yeah they Nvidia summarized something
amazing and and also out of Google did a
paper
the majority of code at Google now is
built by a computer not by a human so
that's one weird way of summarizing this
is when you train a neural network
you're not coding you know if then else
you're setting up the same thing you set
up every time maybe that's des fungible
it's a very fun jables skill set by the
way and you train it and you the
computer is generating its own
executable at the end of the day the
majority of programming is that way now
by a by a factor of ten
so while and every product at Google and
embodies it from search to you know it's
like that is the key technological
things driving across every Google
product so you're so excited by the
science by the engineering
you mentioned product manager meaning
while back yeah and you did in fact do
that for a period time summer jobs so
you know what I have observed not always
but very often at least did when I live
in Silicon Valley certainly that a lot
of engineers have a severe disdain or at
the very least a distaste for all things
most things marketing related right
right it's just I remember that HP just
a bunch of like hand waving
yeah this residents that's them I mean
we got so many levels
yeah what why did you with the
background you have set your sights on
product management yeah so I remember
exactly how this happened I was at you
wait am I getting that right yeah yeah
buddy management marketing credit man
what a dick that's actually the word I
was looking for sorry and in different
firms use the terms differently but I
was open to both some cases it's more
engineering rich other cases it's
whatever so when I Lissette HP I was in
ship design and marketing was in a
different building as it often is and I
basically was getting frustrated even
though it was you know not there very
long on what I saw all around me at
least of HP which was with promote from
within culture you know over 20 years
will become an engineering manager and
like you know most people that were
lifers as we call him and I'd seen kinda
long really dedicate the rest of my life
to that career path and then I said well
how can I accelerate this and that's
when the first idea came wolf I somehow
got into marketing and had you know it
seemed like the boss has more than just
one narrow functional domain like maybe
I should get some experience over there
and then I'd be more of an engineering
manager if I could know more than just
my narrow bare end of engineering I
thought being an enduring manager was
the end goal and learning a bit about
marketing and product marketing because
it was the mystery like how how are all
these decisions that seem to impact our
product development cycles in products
hitting canceled
you know things succeeding or failing in
the market that seemed important Ron
what I was doing and not just did I make
a breakthrough so I wasn't I guess you
could say I wasn't a scientist in my
profession of all I'm just doing it to
learn the best way to do something I I
was engineering the Struma through which
is I want to have an impact I don't want
to design a widget that's gonna sit in a
room and never get used just because I'd
like to design widgets I really would
love to have you know something
meaningful in the world and so that's
why I thought about that and yes there
was a big disdain for marketing amongst
the engineers that I worked with and and
I did finally get a chance that is I
wanted to work with Steve Jobs as well
so I got a chance to work at Apple and
next software was called next there's
when they were moving out of the
hardware business into software only so
but next as it was called um and how
actually wasn't for me either though
I just didn't something's didn't click
about I think maybe my short attention
span and my interest in diverse things
that hunkering down to any one thing
in committing to do it for five years
seemed enough themá-- to mice my course
that's why I left the ph.d program after
two quarters like I'm not going to write
a thesis it's like like spent four years
on one little narrow area of actually
neural networks would have been my
thesis area specifically neural networks
applied to parallel processing computers
was what I was starting down I would
have been fascinated by that but it
would have been 20 years too early
anyway
same thing in any operating job it's
like I would be either job hopping the
way some people do who have this problem
I have or I'd have to be unhappy I think
in my job because it's just the pace of
change in learning would stagnate so
quickly I could see these patterns over
months not years that like I'm not
learning as much anymore on they just
executing the same thing over and over
again and so management consulting was
an intereting way to play to that like
all kinds of different client
engagements it just didn't have the same
agency of making a meaningful impact you
could point you're very vicarious very
diffused and ambiguous whether you've
accomplished anything and that's well
the management's holding firm say we you
know adding value all was talking about
mat and you're measuring how much value
we added all these things are being said
because everyone knows in their heart
like I can't tell them anybody can't
really sing our own praises that much so
so I love the diversity of management
consulting I didn't like the life
balance nor the agency and so when when
finally I discovered venture capital and
learned what it was about it was like
the perfect combination for me well your
investment or at least that facet of
things you haven't see the lens of
looking for things you haven't seen
before right that's also your
programming so to speak right well than
that you can see maybe that's the origin
I hadn't connected those dots but it
seems obvious now as I say this to you
that that desire to seek something new
may have been a driver of that simple
rule that I've been living my life by it
which is in essence something that
annancy me works so when you're looking
at companies and I'm going to come back
to Steve Jobs I have some questions
about Steve and Elon I know you've spent
a good amount of time both when you're
looking at these companies that have no
product that are in the idea stage I
mean there may be some white papers or
publications from think tanks or
conference
panels that discuss these subjects how
do you evaluate deals or how do you vet
deals because I've seen a lot of people
attempt to go as early as you do but
have just gotten their faces ripped off
routinely right so I mean there's there
are and it particularly if you're trying
to be bold so not just invest of the
early stage but also go for things that
are however times however many times out
of 10 going to fail how do you avoid
running out of bankroll right I mean I'd
love to just hear a little bit about
what you what you look for I mean in a
situation like that at that embryonic
stage what are the check boxes that help
you to risk mitigate if that's even a
consideration even though it is in risk
mitigate that right yeah this is the
last one hung me because but part of the
luck I had in starting in the best
intern on for venture you can imagine
the dot-com boom right no small amounts
of capital allow companies to scale
incredibly rapidly there wasn't really
historical precedent for something that
good for venture capital so Chuck part
of this up to look but the side effect
then lasted is that I didn't have that
fearful moment I didn't slog through ten
years of just banging my head against
the wall of failure failure failure
failure it just was like shooting fish
in a barrel to start right so that I
think helped me a build enough track
director that people would give me a bit
more slack to pursue something right
within my partnership for example to
pursue ideas that I can't imagine what
life would be like if I was stuck in a
partnership that wouldn't give me
credibility or let me run with some
ideas right and they certainly would
push back
gloomy Oh SpaceX bunch of companies like
really you're gonna doesn't Rockets are
you kidding me so I get I'd have to
defend some of these but I didn't get
the no no no you can't do this right so
that if I hadn't had that capacity to of
in other words to avoid the inner voice
of doubt and the overt expert a critic
right in both internal and external I
don't think I could have done what I did
in the in the subsequent years so um
fast forward to let's say midway through
my career into the present day so the
startup phase is a little different than
the steady-state so now that we're in
the steady-state I can
realize okay there'll be some failures
that's fine and what I then look for is
a combination of some personal
attributes market attributes and weirdly
of late sort of process technology
attributes so I would have in the past
said a technology breakthrough of course
there has to be you know people you know
huge market and something disruptive in
the technology domain that didn't like -
nanotechnology or something that like we
couldn't have done this five years ago
oh that's another question I always ask
you know every entrepreneur either
explicitly or implicitly if I know the
answer I need to ask it which is could
you started this business five years ago
and if the answer is yes then I don't
want to invest what are other questions
what are other questions another one I'd
love to ask is so what does this
business look like at 10 years and 20
years out and what is mind-boggling is
unfortunately how this weeds out the
charlatans and the you know arbitrage
seeking opportunists like nothing else
lives like deer in the headlights
they've never thought 10 years or 20
years old they don't any idea and it's
not because things change so rapidly
that you can't predict 10 or 20 years
but they don't have a mission they don't
have a purpose for either starting their
business right if you ask you'll unless
that he knows right away yes planet labs
he knows right away yes Zuckerberg he
knows right away you ask Larry Page and
Larry and Sergey Brin they know right
away what their business looks like in
10 and 20 years and you know they have a
mission statement that they hold do
throughout their entire life and it
galvanizes the team it motivates them
did you know that's why they're in
business other people that are called
them arbitrage seekers when people flock
from some industry cuz there's gold in
the hills
um you want to weed that out this is a
great way to weed that out right these
are people's all telling from visions if
they don't really have a purpose for
what they're doing um so so on the
people side I increasingly become
enamored with you know Purpose Driven
businesses as I was mentioned or mission
driven businesses where making money is
not the prime objective it's the
byproduct of the way they intend to
change the world to usher in you know
the transition do sustainable transport
and clean energy to you know colonize
Mars as a couple of easily understood
examples those are both unique there
aren't any other startups at the time
you know proposing to colonize Mars nor
is it something that you get done in a
short period of time it's like the star
on the horizon that galvanizes so much
action um do you want me to look back
those two the the overall categories the
the process
the other love to hear about some of the
attributes and yeah sure so on the
market size I think I think a lot of
venture investors in the early stage
would have the following common answer
to your question I have vested good
people pursuing big ideas in enormous
markets right okay but sometimes they
actually won't execute on that because
enormous markets usually means that it's
something really radical that's changing
there's a lot of unpredictability so if
you're investing in ride-sharing as you
did right before it was obviously a good
idea it was not obviously good idea and
mostly people probably thought it was a
really bad idea well there was a there
was an email that navall rava can't put
up not too long ago which was the the
email that was sent out through
AngelList
which was ignored by something like 297
people out of 300 exactly it was not
clearly a great idea actually I would
see like when I first invest in a
hotmail I felt this I felt that when we
first invest in Skype sidenote really
quickly just because I I'm cheating a
little bit here and I didn't know this
where the name come from how much one
Omaha man it was spelled with a capital
HTML so it was oh we're gonna do
web-based email over HTML it's a big H
small oh yeah exactly is that dorky and
that was it yeah and even more
interesting they because they were
offering free email they put a lot of
effort into the free aspect of this so
they located in Fremont California
come on Liberty Avenue they launched on
the 4th of July which is a national
holiday so they got no news pickup like
that's really it's all free divvy so
anyway those companies were widely
regarded as a bad idea severe of hotmail
famously was turned down by 21 venture
capitalists before he found us and I
would say without a doubt because I've
met whenever these the venture people at
the time the series day was happening
for eBay and Google the vast majority
mention capitals was not invested in the
series a in fact after the series day of
Google the two primary investors
demanded to get their money back they
wanted to be redeemed at costs haha
because of a little spat they were
having what the founders not getting any
CEO not well-known fact or one of the
major venture investors in Apple's
their entire stake pre-ipo you know
they're still bragging about being
invested in Apple of course but you know
people lose faith in the greatest
companies they were invested in I know
we're bouncing around a lot but I
thought that is that's what I like to do
so I was I was just doing a bit of
homework and you're very helpful in
sending me links to a few things one was
an interview with Jason Calacanis oh
yeah I look like a and you had created a
very nifty index of subjects on your on
your Flickr account and one of the
bullets was why I never sell shares of
our companies and biggest misses also
but could you explain what you mean me
of that not sure this is what is never
so never never sell it's a wonderfully
liberating stance and at first people
like me I like you I can see your fish
like that doesn't make sense you know
buy low sell high kind of a munch yeah
yeah no I've never sold a share now let
me have the caveats when I have control
so the vast majority of time in our
business this would apply which is we
invest in a startup it either has an IPO
or it gets acquired those are the two
outcomes where it has a quote liquidity
event and IPO some point after the IPO
years later or at least you know 180
days later a venture firm will
distribute those chairs to its investors
so I as the general partner gets share
so I get shares of Tesla I get shares of
you name it right now what I choose to
do that is my own personal decision
right and and from that point on I've
never sold a share now what I do is give
them the charity over time and some
might argue that's kind of a sales
decision but not entirely it'd be
partially because it's not like I'm
trying to time the market I'm betting on
them in perpetuity and and I'll give you
another answer to why I do this in a
moment but let me just let me flush this
one out a little more this has been
wonderfully goal aligning with
entrepreneurs because if I'm thinking
when is the time to punch out its kind
of a corrosive thought process when
they're thinking I do the ones I like
what am i what's the next 20 years look
like for this business how can we make
the most of it in this next phase of
growth because the best companies are
like these sort of power laws of
compounding potential they you know
would you want to be punching out and
you wouldn't write a facebook of Google
if you know ten years ago god
really a bad mistake right and a little
actually me jump to the point number two
some of the very first advice I got when
I was entering this field was from
someone who had spent their entire
career at the Rockefeller group I forgot
what she was Foundation or something
isn't his Peter crisp and I remember him
vividly because we were I think my first
week on the job it was our first pitch
to people who give us money and here I
met someone who has just coming off a
long career sort of winding down slowly
off a long illustrious career investing
some of the best companies you can
imagine and his two comments to me where
Wow first I'm super envious young group
of people that's starting your career
right now this was like you're gonna
love this I wish I was your age doing
this again this whole second wave so I
just like that Here I am changing
careers as we mentioned earlier not sure
which careers maybe for me that to hear
or something like that and the second
thing is looking back over his whole
career he wish he had never sold
anything and I had a similar reaction
what do you mean he goes well I tried
the time to market and if I had just
held on to my Apple shares right and who
cares what happened to everything else
like the as if held value today it would
have trumped everything else I would be
a much richer man I would have lo
awaited all that anxiety and that echoed
in the back of my mind to this day so in
my I won't show the specifics but in my
personal portfolio there's a similar
power law there is a single company
that's worth more than everything else
combined because I've never sold a share
and if I look at number two may have to
actually I can do the math number two
plus number three probably is that kind
of thing about at longtail exceeds
everything else combined so it's like a
traditional power law and that is pretty
amazing
um so I just like when I made this
decision and also around the same time
to give it all to charity that was
another thing that created a living
trust to give everything but a small
fixed dollar amount to the kids
everything else gonna go to charity then
when you have a major crashes it's not
like I know this is gonna sound weird I
don't stress that I just lost ninety
percent of my net worth because I'd
happen once it's like oh the charity
just lost 90% of his net worth you know
and so I was able to ride it through and
I came right back cuz I didn't panic and
sell and literally lost ninety percent
my net worth um I recall seeing I don't
remember who it was but one of the and
there aren't that many as you know but a
tier venture capital firms looked at
their return on
something or their return to limited
partners of the let's just call it ten
companies that had reached IPO and that
they'd subsequently distributed and they
they compared that with the amount made
by someone who would have invested the
amount in the companies at first
opportunity at IPO and written it out
something like five years and they would
have made just as much money in in in
most of the cases yeah there was a fund
called technology crossover ventures I
think formed with that insight in mind
that says if you can pick some winners
still private and have a judgement from
seeing the track record the passion of
the entrepreneur over a number of years
and then load up the boat either just
pre IPO or at IPO yeah you could put a
large amount of capital work in that but
the key was it was those prior years of
exposure that really gave you confidence
so like my years with Elan allow me to
look at him in a very different way than
other entrepreneurs right yeah and if
you just literally had no prior data and
he just walked in off the street how
would you really know you cement and
yield so you spent time with jobs Elan
many other impressive folks but what
what are the commonalities you've
observed biggest commonalities biggest
differences between those two sure well
let me start with differences because I
think it's tempting to draw an analogy
and I been tempted trust me but I think
it's really important to keep in mind so
I'll start there there's pretty big
differences jobs was a marketing centric
individual with very weak engineering
chops Elon is more of a physicist turn
engineer slash computer scientist
basically deep engineering chops thinks
of everything from first principles of
what can be done from the physics and
then scales up to the product vision
jobs it's much more of a you know like
almost as n Buddhists approach to
parsimonious design and the and the
visceral agitation of if it's
imperfection in design space you know
his the famous calligraphy font thing
and getting rid of all the buttons from
the phone there's all these like
maniacal missions he had where at no
point did he clearly lay out like well
here's the business strategy like he get
rid of the buttons
everything left in the cloud you have
software services later you can iterate
more quickly like this is gonna be an
awesome business opportunity from Get
Rid all the buttons I think that was
like no buttons are ugly get rid of them
that's that's [ __ ] that design a [ __ ]
you know he would say but he wouldn't
really give this like ah I get it
that's the master plan right where's
Elon is like master plan part 1 that's
the plan part do ya the French um he
lays it all out and he's basically
executing corn in the master plan
there's actually a really well thought
out series of steps to get from here to
colonizing Mars a serious steps to get
rid of the petrochemical economy which
is pretty amazing and it's all there for
anyone to read that that's like night
and day difference now similarities
simple and you know CEO to companies I
think that's interesting structurally
not too many people have the Shutts but
to do that and I think by the way in
both cases it allows you to focus
interestingly in a way that you couldn't
no I see you're saying sorry yeah I
heard that sense to a CEO two companies
each of them independently CEO so two
companies X you got Pixar and and and
either next or Apple depending on
timeframe to be fair Jobs was really not
quite the CEO at Pixar buddy us by title
in any case what you can do though is
avoid meetings imagine you know it's the
company holiday party and you just don't
want to go all right no one's gonna
double guess like you're no I'll see you
and normal coming you avoid your own
holiday party like what'd you have to do
um but this this is awesome you can
basically avoid time wasting meetings
and you have to delegate more and so in
both cases it is an intriguing thought
experiment that being CEO more than one
company has some interesting benefits
for both companies huh
yeah never thought of it though you know
um the similarity I think there's one
area in design where the the maniacal
attention to detail I described it as
this visceral agitation that I mean
almost painful to Steve Jobs to see
things that were not right there's a bit
of that in any on as well I interviewed
him once about design and it sounded so
spooky we so similar in that regard but
in a completely different wrapper I mean
you know you wouldn't really know or see
it as a similar vector of like like both
think it's just easy and maybe it's the
sign of brilliance that just there's
certain parts of this whole space that
are intuitive
and they do naturally and I wish I knew
how to do it myself and be spotted and
others yeah right so everyone will also
wants to ask like how can I raise my kid
to be like Elon or how can I you know
find entrepreneurs that are like him and
if you if you think about just one
element of that and how miraculous it is
to be able to go into a number of
industries you know commercial banking
arguably with PayPal the aerospace
industry with SpaceX the automotive
sector the you know the energy competing
with utilities with the solar city idea
really left-field now it's part of Tesla
but when it started is really a
left-field sector it wasn't one industry
I was like lots of energy generation
that's like competing with regulated
utilities um without any prior business
experience in those sectors to become
the dominant company in all of them have
failed it none of them to be the most
important company in all those fields is
kind of mind-boggling yeah okay right
and the thing that I look for in
companies that say we got this mission
as I was mentioning but we're gonna get
this through incremental steps and
engaging with customers all along the
way we're not just gonna like hunker
down for 20 years and then pop out with
colonizing Mars in the other end to
actually paint the picture how we get
from here to there that's even more
miraculous in some ways it's like
everyone can have a big dream like oh
yeah like thousands of people could have
the dreams that Elon has almost none of
them can paint a compelling picture how
to get there mm-hmm that's really what's
your 10-year vision what's your 20 year
vision that comes into play so Elon has
this mythical status for so many people
I mean just this kind of Superman who's
got everything figured out I found this
article on Business Insider I was
talking a little bit about your
relationship with him and there are two
things one I'll just actually to two
questions I asked the first is he called
him the most risk immune person I've
ever met and then then I follow up to
that but what what does that what's
what's an example of him being risk
immune yeah and is it because he does is
it because he feels differently in the
face of the same risk or is it because
he defines risk differently or something
like that yeah that's a great question
because I think it's passed through the
filter of the observer we perceive risk
incredible
and some of the things he's done I don't
know that we have perfect vision on and
how could we unreal II does he perceive
the risk the same way we do right as
external observers and so I think part
of the answer and his brother made a
somewhat similar statement once so I
feel comfortable at least talking about
this not as if I'm speaking out of
school that um they're like here's one
make it stated externally I've never
seen an entrepreneur go all in for his
companies and I say plural Elan like
some entrepreneur if they'll quit a job
they'll spend their entire life savings
on some idea they'll do whatever right
the personal commitment personal
sacrifice I've never seen anything like
it on and the I think this story came
out where I was referring back to
December 2008 yeah this in the in the
darkest period for Tesla mmm-hmm yeah so
yeah must glad it would take 50 million
to get his first trip to Mars and then
next sentence he was 200 million
he was 200 million in and had quote
spent all of his money between that and
Tesla and he went into personal debt and
by 2008 exactly so 2008 for those that
might remember was financial crisis was
happening for context at that time Tesla
had just gotten rid of a CEO Elon was
not had not been the CEO up until then
and it was tough a large investment bank
one of the most prestigious had just
failed to do a fund raise this is where
you hire them pay them lots of money go
out get us the money you know you
expected to come in at the end of this
process they're like sorry we have
nothing for you and the company was
rapidly running out of money in fact it
was heading towards December 2008 in and
it couldn't make payroll on so Elon
wrote a cheque personally for three
million dollars just so they can make
the December Christmastime payroll of
the employees but like January's gonna
be just as bad and there's like no money
anywhere there was and by the way for
context there was no government program
there was no Daimler investment at this
point it was just a company that had a
roadster that was negative gross margin
meaning every car you sell you lose more
money it was a surprise discovery how
bad the proposition was this my CEO was
let go it was like oh my god like
contrary to our belief are actually
losing money on every car and that's not
easy to fix by the way several cars does
not solve this problem really readily
and you had your largest inside investor
this is a term of art in the venture
community
there's a lot of symbolism when your
largest investor is or is not supportive
of what you're doing it doesn't know
doesn't mean they actually have a thing
that cantilever they can pull to kill
you or but but the symbolisms bags that
are in the trenches with you and if
they're refusing to write a check that's
a really hard fundraising environment
and the largest investor was as hostile
as I've ever seen an investor they did
not want any loss CEO they did not want
anything who the company they wanted to
pivot to a different business strategy
that seemed a little too cozy that it
would support one of their limited
partners and that felt really icky and
they were openly hostile so oh and he
was going through a divorce and SpaceX
rockets were blowing up by the way and
he spent every penny he had so what does
he do he borrowed twenty million dollars
and he said ok we don't our lead
investors not here this large investment
bank has failed I'm gonna invest the 40
million dollars that's needed not lead
in half for teaming dollars I'm gonna
invest the 40 million dollars is needed
to hell with all of you here the terms
about the holiday but like I'm doing it
trains leaving the station and it
flipped the zeitgeist if you will from
fear to greed right and this is what it
meaning everyone's thinking what does he
see that I don't see and to be fair
there is a there is a dynamic which I'm
sure you've seen which is you can have a
bunch of people on the table like we
were no dfj was very enthusiastic and
wanted to invest but we can't do the
full 40 million and we need somebody to
be the lead investor and we'll do our
full share Tory we actually did more
than our full share but somebody's got a
step further this missing nut when your
largest insider won't and you don't have
any outside money someone's gotta set it
up so he stepped up said I don't care
I'll do the whole thing if need be
who's with me and we took as much as we
could we brought a growth fund in for
the first time and it's it is an easier
decision to say will I write a check
let's say for two million dollars let's
say you're just one of the random
investors there as part of 40 knowing
that at least is 40 at least we're gonna
get through this
roaster cost problem and be able to turn
some cards if you will see does the
government come through does the daimler
relationship actually happen because
there's verbal conversations going on
we'll get resolution at least those
major things and so there'll be hope to
get to the next phase of actually
building the Model S car if all that
falls in our favor let's be part of it
so our two million dollar check
leverages the 40 million dollar check
I'm just saying to arbitrarily yeah so
if you if you're all you can do is write
two million dollar checks you would
never just write to me I'll check
like like a like a pure it's not a
bridge to something it's like a you know
and that's what a Ilan was willing to do
in December all by himself and then B he
was willing to do another one all by
himself I've never seen him like it so
he in retrospect was perfectly right
everything went exactly according to
plan this is gonna change the world it's
gonna be an enormous ly valuable company
this was an incredibly good investment
to make at the time in retrospect at the
time it seemed like the riskiest thing
I've ever seen I've never seen an
entrepreneur fund their own company you
know first when no one else would second
go net negative by 20 million dollars I
unbelievable did you have you asked him
what he was thinking at the time not
directly I didn't want to I liked it
like this is great it just felt like the
right thing is like I could see the fear
going to greed oh by the way in tough
times you sometimes also learn who is
gonna stand by you and who won't well
then so that that lead investor and then
also maybe I won't mention the names
there's at least one board member was
like oh my gosh they showed their
stripes yeah and there's nothing like a
crisis to know if you're in the trench
with the right person yeah who your
Fairweather friends are yeah it's a to
that point in the it's mentioned in this
piece that even called you around the
darkest times right so during some of
these really tough periods what did and
it doesn't of course keeping it whatever
private should be private but what is
someone like Ilan you've interacted with
a number of these people who have
incredible capacity to do big things
what does someone like that say to a
friend during their dark times I mean
why do they call friends well I do I'm
not gonna relay anything specifics but I
could try to get to the gist of the
question I won't relate any specifics to
the phone call and to be fair I don't
even really remember the specifics
because I've been so many calls over so
many times so so with the caveat of
because because if you look at the list
of difficulties he was going through
like any one of those yeah be
soul-crushing it's all cursing
completely paralyze and send millions of
people into a downward spiral so it so
he has said some things like I don't
want to speak out schools but there is
something I can share that might be
helpful he has spoken himself and it was
like eating glass that this was like
really
time so he's made some comments
personally I was let him speak for what
it felt like for him but I would say
that what I've observed in that crisis
and other crises that we generalize is
that he goes into a battle mode of focus
that is really remarkable in this battle
mode is allows him I think to ignore
distraction and to have a laser focus on
what needs to get done so it'll
sometimes be I will observe it as these
sort of thoughtful deep moments of like
wow you see it on its face and you want
to give him space to think because I
think there's like four people that
could be times in your generative and
thoughtful and brainstorming and like
thinking about all possibilities in the
wonder of the world the other times
means like you got it like solve a
problem and like focus in and and in
those modes he can avoid distraction
like no one else I've seen so a lot of
the smart CEOs and entrepreneurs I've
worked with are are some of them share
afterwards that I have in spades which
is I'm interested in many things I'm
easily distracted by something and
sometimes I'd rather avoid the tough
crisis in my you know in thinking about
it when there's something more fun to
spend time on right and so I'm almost
the opposite of this well just to give
credit to how valuable this is when
let's say Tesla has faced various
manufacturing challenges these sort of
production hell times that he's
described he physically sets up his
office on the production floor in a very
visible area with no walls so everyone
can see that he's there through the
weekend they know the vice-presidency
that ripples out when he's calling a
supplier let's say he was often the
cause of a problem is like well I'm here
in the factory were you did you hear
solving this for us yeah it has a lot of
impact right that personal attention to
right now everything else needs to be
gone I have to solve this problem I
witnessed this for example in a more
subtle way more recently when I was
setting up or trying to set up rather a
very interesting phone call between the
Mars Azara Persinger the Mars
exploration program for NASA craig
Venter who's a pioneer in psychology and
gene sequencing and gene synthesis and I
want to just get Elon a half-hour call
because the sort of idea had occurred
amongst us that we could do a much
cheaper Mars return mission in other
words but if there's any life on Mars
either you know archaic or currently
living the best way to explore it would
be not to send it back from Mars
but the Senate gene sequencer Tamar's
sequencing locally beamed the data back
and create the living organism on earth
that's actually is doable and I thought
Elin should certainly be interesting
this cousin like the next phase of Mars
exploration terraforming finding out
what organisms do live on Mars or not if
they mutate on Mars and actually start
thriving send the data back create a
version on earth to study it here and
more rapidly telephone Mars he's like
you know that's great he said I can't
take that phone only half hour phone
call I one day that would be important
right now I get it get it Falcon Heavy D
fly or there won't be that need for me
to be doing that so his I'm like I would
love this half hour phone call where I
wants us really he's like that back in
late years and it can right now
um and that remarkable ability to push
aside all these interesting things when
there's I gotta get XYZ to ship or fix
the problem and so fixing the gross
margin problem back in 2008 getting a
CEO what should not to be himself in
place and solving all the myriad
problems that were in place was battle
mode and yeah he would also lean on
confidence and friends so to be fair
there were others like Antonio gracias
and others who really rolled up their
sleeves got on the faculty was a close
friend yeah he's amazing so folks like
that really come and you know prove that
there's some of those diable of esters
out there Antonio is happy to to fight
to support his friends to exactly I'll
just say I used my favorite investor
I've ever met in my entire no we're
kidding up so I mean kids up moreover
the rubato lying about this but so we
were Antonio now were in the henrique
rent fellowship program the Aspen
Institute so we we've had a chest spent
a lot of time together
yeah great guy absolutely great guy said
two things come to mind the first is and
I'm sure I'm gonna butcher this but I I
it's a quote attributed to Steve Jobs I
feel like there are a lot of missed
tributed quotes I'm pretty sure this is
accurate I don't think it's an Abe
Lincoln situation on the Internet yeah
but that innovation is saying no to a
thousand things that the I haven't
written but yeah in any case the other
was he's also by the way Jobs was very
proud of when I saw his greatest
creation or greatest contribution to the
world as greatest invention his greatest
thing you know on his death but it was
Apple the organization and and it was
really the process learning coming back
to something I was starting talked about
earlier he was focused on visible
design keeping engineers in the
marketing people think about where the
bathrooms are at Pixar so you have to
walk by certain areas to get to them huh
he was maniacal about architecting the
way people communicate kicking people
out of meetings if they're too big so he
had an intuitive sense of a team size
along before I did now if the people are
over a certain weight class no no no no
no you don't want 27 people on anything
productive no development team actually
fives the ideal number five plus or
minus two boards of directors
development teams creative groups that's
the one of the secret managers of small
companies that they have less people
yeah and they get [ __ ] done when it's a
big company has hundreds of people and
sclerotic layers of management that
they've lost the small team dynamic hmm
so I always like to ask about and asked
about it with Elon the some of the
tougher times because more challenges
because it's it's easy I think and I
explore this with lots of everybody
who's on the show I try to ask them
about how they go how they try to deal
with overwhelm or if they feel scattered
what do they do and we talked a little
about a little bit about Elon I'd love
to ask you because you recently had an
experience that a lot of people have in
the sense that I and many others get
their turn as kind of the the punching
bag if you're public-facing I mean
you're gonna run into things and you had
an experience recently that I'd love for
you to describe if you're open to it and
then I have some follow-up questions
just about how you then reacted to it
right the self-talk and things like that
so maybe if I could just leave it over
there so yeah maybe it's an elephant the
room but in the last couple months I
have faced the most surreal experience
of my career which is you know what some
23 years of venture capital and many
before that all positive press
experiences and then I faced a bizarre
it's almost autocatalytic you know
self-generating theme that I hosted a
sex party with my fiance in Silicon
Valley and at first I laughs this is
hilarious you know as an ex gig you know
growing up my whole life with you know
glasses and braces and what-have-you
like the notion I mean my first date was
in college you know like I really
thought that was hilarious at first then
it got a little more serious like wait
this this
is ridiculous um and they're really the
thing that's even when it came it
derived from a book that and then came
out in February where there's no such
claim that we hosted a sex party but
it's in a chapter about sex parties that
other people had and we just happened to
be the only party that has been anyone
mentioned by name and then it I mean if
I try to put a simplistic spin on this
or try to make sense of it it looks like
people just didn't read the chapter very
carefully and they wait blog posts or
other like very sort of non professional
postings online that oh my gosh the sex
party who was at Steve's house like what
would she not only the book mats say
that it wasn't true and by the way
there's 150 people that attended this
thing but no it's not true and like 10
of them go publicly on which is kind of
a risky thing they do say I was at this
party and there was no sex including
ulong and the mess he's like this is
irresponsible journalism or something
that effect and he condemned the writer
and like like and it's kind of bizarre
because I know this author I've been on
her you know Bloomberg television
program many times she knows my email
she knows my cell phone she never called
me for a fact check which I didn't
realize in book publishing today in
what's ostensibly a nonfiction category
that the publishers do no fact-checking
that's just a fact now it's transformed
from decades ago and they leave it up to
the writer and the writer just just
didn't even try to see how it was true
and more disturbingly would retweet even
though she never said we had a sex party
she would retweet other people who did
so some you know other publication and
Europe would say oh the the orgy alright
so it starts to grow the orgy at her
house and she retweets it really you
know this isn't true and I know she
knows it isn't true but she keeps
retweeting it because it sells more
books yeah and I know executives for
example who've been pressured by their
PR people to say positive things about
the book because of her ongoing role as
a bloomberg reporter she have this weird
yeah conflict of interest when you want
to sell books and salacious stories sell
to propagate something that's not true
even if you didn't say it yourself
you know and then turn around and use
your leverage and your bully pulpit on
Twitter and elsewhere to gain support
for your book because you know people
want to continue working with you and
you're gonna be the journalist of record
in the tech industry at one of the
biggest news organizations it's kind of
unfair
yes feels really horrible ask you like
how did it how did it feel and what was
your self-talk maybe in the short term
and then I asked a lot of people about
self-talk which I'm fascinated by it's
sort of the day of let's just say when
it ceases to be funny okay and then
maybe I'm making this up in terms of
timeline but like a few days later and
you've had a chance to maybe gather your
thoughts a bit yeah so despite the
initial burst almost like this defensive
aha this is funny you know and then when
I really allowed at the sink and we took
some number of hours and like you know
like for example is 150 probably more in
total 150 that really knew there was
nothing there and they were there the
whole time they have to explain to their
spouses and others like no I really
wasn't at a sex party that's really what
everything I think those poor people
totally innocent um anyway and again not
to condemn a sex party I mean I've never
been invited the one I've never held one
I don't want to say it's a terrible
thing
let's just say I haven't been the one I
don't want to be accused of one just
just as did to inject some levity real
quickly so I just moved to San Francisco
this was a long time ago and one of my
neighbors said Oh welcome to the
neighborhood you should come over
Saturday like we're having a party
that's like sure no problem so I end up
like I'm gonna like dinner I'm like okay
the too late no it's not too late come
on over so I walk in and I'm like well
that's happening here like people in
various states of undress and just in
time to realize oh my god I'm actually
at a sex bar like there's food served
but I'm like fully clothed with a beanie
and up and a hoodie on and then they go
okay everybody sit down we're gonna do a
round of introductions and so I sit down
a like way how do I get out of this cuz
they're like 4050 people there and I did
manage to scurry out and then then say
to my neighbor
well I won't name my name but I was just
like please in the future let me know
okay give me a heads up like I have
nothing against it but it's like let me
know what's going on in any case that's
like you're in the Bay Area right soon
sink I'm sure these things happen I know
a little one it's not my thing so so I
don't want to sound too preachy because
you know but it's just not my thing and
it does feel weird to have you know a
room full of tech executives and you
know some of our closest business
colleagues you know scores of them
maligned in this indirect way so um
we felt though is I felt really betrayed
and there were and it wasn't just the
single journalist that I've highlighted
like wow what happened to professional
journalistic ethics like just
fact-checking and caring about the truth
that's one branch of disappointment the
other was a little more invisible I'll
keep this anonymous but there were a
number of people I noticed who would
immediately lend support to this idea
online like either simple things like
you know retweeting something without
checking with me you know people who
ostensibly know me that was really
disappointing so I felt betrayed by
luckily only a handful I mean a
remarkably small number of people who
just and frankly there's some of my
least well-known contacts so these
aren't close personal friends that are
like myths the other venture capitalist
let's say just as a category you know on
the other side I was blown away by the
outpouring of support by people who do
know me so a couple of you know
co-workers of ex employees that I used
to work with came out with blog posts
that in every case it was after they
published that I even knew they were
putting something together coming in my
defense and like female entrepreneurs of
all types right now is anything but this
happened at this event um and we'll be
eternally grateful for again when time
is really tough you you find out a bit
more about people's character and you
find out who is really someone who knows
you guys someone who knows me knows is
not true right and what's weird is that
I thought that be obvious for a larger
set but at least the ones who really
know me they don't need to ask about it
right they don't know oh my god dude
what's going on this is crazy right yeah
so what prevented you I mean you have
the outpouring of support you also had a
few people show their true colors some
people when they get hit with something
like that anything I mean I've had
periods where it's like I remember this
kind of hit piece came out on me and I'm
not saying these are the same thing but
like it's hit piece came out I mean it
came out on my birthday at one point
where I have this annual gathering of my
closest friends and it was through
credible I mean a very well known
publication that had not only they had
contacted me for fact-checking via phone
I had corrected a bunch of Mis quotes
and then they ran it as is without
making any of the changes and it really
bummed me out like I was considering not
doing any interviews ever
the future maybe I'll have to make a
number of changes to my life so that I'm
not exposed and I think that there are
certain ways you can mitigate it like
always doing fact checking email email
responses as opposed to - they can't
deny you've always had I did - email I
mean there are a number of different
ways that you can risk me to get there
but was there was there anything that
you said to yourself or that other
people said to you that was particularly
helpful at the time I think about that
for a second um well the thing that
jumps to mind is how supportive my
fiancee Genevieve was throughout this I
mean she's a fighter and she was at my
side throughout in some ways it was
incredible
and I'm incredibly thankful for her
support throughout this um at the
beginning of what you were saying the
part that it was going through my mind
was you were asking question is that one
of the toughest things in it relates to
advice other people gave me was the
advice to not say anything mmm the
advice to be just mom I got advice from
people who focus on PR I got advice from
people who've been through similar
situations or worse I've been accused of
crazy things or you know like crimes
right yeah you know falsely accused of
crimes which luckily I've never been
accused of and in every single case like
with like zero crack of there's another
side to this point of view is like you
say nothing you do not point out the
obvious flaws in these false accusations
in the in the research supporting this
is disturbing but true that anything you
say even definitively proving your
innocence will only worsen people's
perception of you at large
just the mere recanting or resurfacing
of that topic - then say it has been
decidedly proven false you know make
people think worse of you on average now
from from a media perspective so in
private conversations that that's not
the case and I've asked psychologists
about this I don't know all the studies
like real clinical / science driven
studies show that you do not want to say
anything even to prove your own
innocence so that's horrible you know
right it's like that's where you're torn
up with all the virtual conversations
you would like to have with the people
who've done you wrong with
Media is because you know you can set
the record straight like I wrote pages
of stuff that I never used yeah like
let's just set the record straight like
I could in my mind played for months I
would play through you know well here's
what I would say that with just either a
clear it all up or B get back at the
person who I know is being dishonest to
prove they're being dishonest right yeah
like now fess up like how about you own
this one yeah so that is the most
difficult I really a hard time with that
because in every advertiser my life I
don't have to do that you can speak
openly about like I disagree with you
well that didn't really happen or that's
a science-based fact you know or
something yeah I mean X scientists I
hate that well it's it seems like this I
mean you were able to withstand the flak
very well if you think back on it could
be at any point in your life but has
there ever been a particularly difficult
period for you I mean and that you know
no I mean my whole high school I could
say but that was a long retracted series
of pain of just feeling insecure and
like I was a late bloomer I mean I tell
you about tough times but there wasn't
like a shock to the system there wasn't
like I mean I was deeply I mean hurt
when my dad died I mean that that was
tough but it was something that's that's
life it was a natural cause you know I
qualify so it was tough yeah I mean I
the remorse and so I got through some
tough things but nothing that was quite
like this which is wow that really
someone did me wrong yeah I've been
betrayed as opposed to happy you know
life has its cycles and I can feel sad
about the passing of a dear loved one
but it's different category I think ya
know yeah really different categories
but the I'm interested still in the
coping mechanisms or the the thinking
that goes with us when your dad died mmm
no I'm sorry for your loss it's hard for
you to imagine but what was most helpful
during the period of grieving or
recovering from that it wasn't I didn't
have a playbook of what to do and what
seemed most natural and it may have been
the habit of mind was to focus on my mom
and helping her yeah who survived him
who was there I decided when he passed
um about of a heart attack um it's just
one of those things were like why you
trying never having we're trying to call
911 for I was like that was my heart
went out so much to her and how her
situation was worse than mine in a way
that that consumed almost all my
thoughts for some period of time dealing
with you knows that I'm the only child
in that family dealing with what needs
to be dealt with he's just I went into
sort of almost non emotional operations
mode and may have been sometime late
that night or the next day that I
finally was I allowed myself to cry and
really face what I had lost part of what
gave me incredible solace is perhaps
some wisdom I could pass on the others
who worried about parents who go and I
know Tim urban and others have written
some wonderful pieces about you know
think about your parents if you have
anyone there are parents generous like
how many days do you have left
yeah the yes the tail-end yes everybody
should read it absolutely it was
recommended to me just as a quick side
note by Matt Mullenweg a mutual friend a
wonderful person who also lost his
father not too long ago and he
recommended to me before it happened
exactly so maybe the thing that I took
solace in that I'll shared for others is
it's not what you do and the weeks
before someone passes that really
defines your relationship it's what
you've done over your life and so I have
been going to the TED Conference I
brought him with me it was one of the
greatest joys of his life for years
prior the fact that we had all those
weeks together sort of these one-on-one
times of intellectual pursuits in this
way almost a welcome into my world that
I take dad the workday in a sense in
this sort of sort of virtual world of
like ideas and science technology when
he went through his he went through a
pancreatic surgery procedure and just
around Thanksgiving and came out of it
and then I was told by the nurse who
first saw him when he came out of it was
that because there was a chance he
wouldn't make it even through the
procedure it's good at EDD again that's
that's amazing and so hearing that then
he had complications a few weeks later
that he passed from but just knowing how
much that meant him and how much time I
did get to spend with them purposefully
was really took the edge off like if you
were estranged if I
was at odds with him then I'd really be
torn up with guilt of having not come to
closure and we had nothing he's my hero
we I've only had positive thoughts about
him felt my life so I made it easier
ironically to lose the guy that I had
the best friendship with yeah I mean
this is as you said it's part of the
cycle I'm certainly not looking forward
to it I mean people have asked me like
what do you fear or what are you afraid
of and they're you know there's
certainly things not not as many as one
might expect I mean I don't be eaten by
sharks or anything like I don't spend a
lot of time dwelling on the fear of that
happening that's like watching my
parents get older and ultimately pass
away is something that I yeah I think
qualifies definitely something that
occupies my mind and I owe Matt a huge
debt of gratitude because he led me to
the tail end I read the tail end and
that led me a number of years ago to
start taking extended trips with my
parents twice a year so at six-month
intervals we have not just the trip
which is usually let's just call it two
to three weeks but where I usually take
them somewhere they haven't been but
also the entire period in between during
which we can look forward to the trim
and plan the trip and talk about the
trip and that anticipation I feel like
is there 70 80 percent of the enjoyment
of it exactly and so I owe Matt a huge
thank-you and he recommended a book to
me I haven't yet read but I'm hoping to
soon which I believe is on grief and
grieving and he's been on the podcast
people look up his last name and grief
and grieving sure the correct title if
that isn't it will pop up but he
recommended that everyone read it even
before passing of loved ones so we
talked about Matt Mullenweg I I pinged
him to ask him what subjects more
questions might be interesting to
explore and one of them was parenting so
it's it's a good segue how do you think
about parenting or do it maybe doing it
differently this is too awkward a
question to answer but what are some of
the things that you think are important
in parenting well you know we don't
really get manuals on how to do it you
know the people young parents and
first-time parents are sort of thrust
into it and you find your own way the
thing I the only thing I did prepare for
being a parent was to read scientists in
the crib by Ellison
Nik it's a not a parenting book it's
basically about the neuroscience of
infants and you know through two and
three years old that made it fascinating
to study and I mean literally this
incredible creature when they were pre
verbal it sort of created a bond that
some dads lack I think when they don't
have that physical connection and it's a
nursing or what-have-you that a mom
might have and yet to marvel at this
creation that is in front of you
the things like how they pick up
language how they a vision system
develops it that actually gave me I'm
going to under strange rattle here but
it gave me strange experiments to run
like pushing the bassinet on the first
day of life under a light overhead that
was an l-shape and the baby's eyes would
open immediately every time one other
there because you could actually see it
through the closed eye and any edge
detection just fires up the brain so
like you have visitors you like this
nice open um and then during phony and
development meeting learning and
language taxing button sounds because
like it's sort of we take it for granted
but we learn how to speak by watching
others like what are you doing with your
lips to make that sound right so me they
made young childhood development easy
then I got into my groove which is like
my power Ally which is playing with like
kids getting down at their level whether
it's Legos or blocks or whatever and
just exploration and fun so what I loved
about being apparently early years was
an excuse to rediscover Mindstorms NXT
or Legos in general then Mindstorms
which got so much better the toys have
gotten so much better than drones and
right so when the kids are older but
basically playing with kids to me is
super invigorating and metaphorically I
think a lot of engineers scientists and
people close to that field like even
venture capitalists would do well to try
to be creative like a child to engage
like a child does with the world well in
that shelve like Wonder yeah that's
interrupt but this this brings to mind
and just for longtime listeners the
reason that I'm not going to ask a lot
of my rapid-fire questions that I
normally do is because Steve you're kind
enough to answer a good a good number of
them in my last book Charlie mentors but
in that I asked you what you would put
on a billboard and you said celebrate
the childlike mind yeah so I I mean I
don't to interrupt the discussion right
here it's almost like a mantra that came
out of parenting which is I could see
how
and then this is something by the way
that harkens back indirectly through
this book scientists in the crib that
babies are like scientists they form
conjectures and hypotheses they test the
world if entrusted putting things in
their mouths or playing with everything
sometimes it frustrates a parent but
when you see them as scientists doing
experiments and learning how the world
works from a sort of boot up face it is
metaphorical for what we lose EFT
oftentimes after many years of
traditional education that can I beat
the creativity out of you and I think
the best engineers and the best
scientists have that kind of a childlike
mind you can see it in the writings of
fine mine and find in an even Einstein
and Newton and others like Newton I
think once famously said I felt like
nothing but a child playing on this on
the sheets or that there's something
deeply resonant about seeing the
connectivity in things as a child would
and avoiding the strictures in mental
ruts that academic disciplines foster
and job sort of tracks anything about
discipline track those are both two
things I don't like yeah I'd rather have
less discipline and less tracks right
I'd rather be exploratory and creative
and so um I found children to be a
wonderful opportunity it's in a such a
win-win you're connecting with them
you're mindful your presence and that
later rolls into reading with them and I
spend a lot of time and tried to
whenever I'm with them do what they like
to do
all right engage with them and the kinds
of toys and things that they like and
then push that a little further with all
kinds of actually put it you know tech
infused adjuncts to what they might
normally be playing with you know we'd
probably have time to go into it right
now on in this conversation but people
where can people learn about your
rockets
your rocket building so I did a short
TED talk on the the joys of rocketry oh
yeah I think it's called the joys of
rocketry so ever since my son turned
three we started launching a model
rocket site in this story there was I
just went to a local toy store back when
they had them you know a physical place
and saw this sd's rocket kit you know
ready to fly am I I sort of remember
rockets until I wasn't that into them
I'd built a couple and so we did this in
to make long story short I found a
mentors I could teach me like you know
you can get really bigger engines and
bigger rockets to
to the present day I've probably
launched thousands of rockets I 3d print
these designs to my son I've been
working on this we got to the Black Rock
Desert every year and launched like
really big things going well past
supersonic speeds routinely launching
large rockets the Rockets he could fit
inside as a hobby that's by the way
where I first met planet Labs was out in
the desert launching rocket you know as
an aside so occasional good business
comes out of it too but most of all it's
this incredible hobby of making science
real like when something fails to launch
or explodes on the pad or you know comes
back in because the parachute didn't
deploy properly it is just visually
exciting I don't know I just I can't
really put my finger on why it's not
universally exciting to me it just feels
like something everyone should do a
little bit of talking about making
science real there were there were a few
tidbits that I pulled from one of your
your indices on various talks and they
were just seemed like fantastic
attention grabbing headlines that
they're not intended to be that as like
you know I'd be interested in hearing
the answer or just a little bit of
elaboration on this one was drones and
how to eliminate the TSA so what's
what's the short ish it doesn't have to
be super sure but explanation of what
that means
sure and so the drones thing is
peripheral but how to eliminate the TSA
was as an epiphany I had back I think it
was around 2005 or maybe earlier maybe
2003
post 9/11 TSA is you know got in full
effect doing all kinds of crazy things
you know I think we they just
implemented the shoe thing for the first
time and I'm at this sort of
brainstorming effort with them where
they gave us the challenge you know how
can we rapidly erratically streamline
airport security operations to get on
the plane sooner and this was at the
time looking out 18 years I don't know
why 18 years maybe it was 2002 and this
would be 2020 maybe I'm right maybe was
2002
and so I came to the I think was the
only tech guy there the only one
eighteen years that's a long time to
predict things we'd invested by the way
in some airport security technology
stuff but I didn't really talk about any
of that I was like 18 years that's going
to be you know
perhaps 18 doublings of moore's law
which would be you know 256,000 X
compute power hmm what might someone do
then that they couldn't do now well
autonomous flight it's like this is left
by the way is long before Thomas driving
or Thomas flight or drones was a thing
like that those words didn't exist right
um at least not in vernacular products
on the ice there's no question that we
could have a ton was flight by then 18
years in the future by year 2020 like
autonomous planes cuz we ready can today
right by the way Airbus and Boeing every
one of those planes gonna land better
than the pilot could and take off
everything but taxing is easy compared
to autonomous driving any case um no one
else was on that page and I said well
wait you guys what happened is there's
no cockpit you made that a really nice
first-class lounge the plane can't be
used as a weapon right so why have any
security gateway right so just what you
could do instead is go in with some
biometrics we know who's on the plane
have video surveillance in the plane as
the trade off and bring whatever weapon
you want on the plane this would be a
really bad place to go kill 200 people
right because you're gonna get caught
right if you're a terrorist cell you
will get caught if you can't use it as a
terrorist weapon then why have the TSA
at all and then there was the wall
Webley will it really work and it will
to have a thomas fight we should we
should be doing it today with today's
technology no doubt about it and you
could telematic aliy operate at each
airport for the taxi part if that's
really so hard um but anything that's
not heard and then you could take go
step further saying okay well what about
bombs you know made the plane falls out
this guy your luggage would fly
separately an autonomous thing from the
plane itself you know a smaller luggage
only plane for the actual cargo part you
could have smaller planes you know that
the whole design space starts to change
in terms of what the optimal design is
if you're not amortize in a pilot
anymore in terms of that operational
costs and you could have multiple
flights where there was a single one
before now there's even less people per
plane and more flexibility in your
routes all the sun packs and I asked
them like have you even calculated the
economic impact of the shoe policy and
they didn't know what I meant like we
could just take like how much time that
I just add to the queue of the average
traveler times the average salary of the
average American and just a economic
deadweight loss like you know and part
of what I tried to show them is that the
immune response of a system is often
worse and what kills you not a pathogen
right so it's often our own immune
system that kills us literally as the
method of death
and I said wait how long till someone
like puts a battery on fire are you
gonna keep the laptops and cell phones
off the plane do you realize the
economic impact of that and they don't
want to hear it I'm glad that hasn't
happened quite yet but I'm like that's
what the terrorist cells should be doing
that causes harm just like have one
Yahoo make a half-assed attempt to light
a battery on fire on a plane and now
look what I do like yeah I was in a
flight firm I want to say it was I mean
I was in a far-flung place betting was
Uzbekistan to Istanbul or Istanbul to
London it was one of the two and we
actually had to surrender all of our
laptops and it created the amount of
confusion and congestion and craziness
that that created was just unbelievable
yeah yeah so the the end of the TSA
that's right
would that be wonderful how do you how
do you budget as a technology investor
for regulatory or political opposition
from incumbents mm-hmm I mean you could
look at I mean many different examples
of this whether it's lobbyists or
extremely powerful unions of various
types that would be strongly strongly
strongly incentivized to not allow sound
like the TSA to yeah no no I lost unions
I mean some people would point out the
the usual like well I got a bit of an
issue here um so in the past in the 90s
especially when the internet was like
you could just do internet for a while
and that was fine we had the mantra that
never invest in a regulated sector or
Sur and still to this day try not to I
try not to invest anything that requires
any law to get passed in order to be in
business and right the one exception is
we went all in an autonomous driving or
you know the product is currently
illegal but we know it's gonna become
legal all right fully level five
autonomous driving but without exception
recently in the old school if we not
only try to avoid regulate invited to
deal with in any way as a customer or
partner with you know utilities or the
government or in any of that sector but
I think frankly that left a lot of large
sectors just plump like a lot of
entrepreneurs we're avoiding them like
the plague so when Ilan opened our eyes
it says you can actually take on what
might be perceived to be the most
non-market if you will you know or
non-market factors not like the best
product doesn't necessarily win nothing
the old Terry Industrial Complex right
you think that on head-on and just win
with a better product hmm right
and similarly going up against the
regulated utilities with solar cities
and like sort of distributed solar
solution and yes they're fighting with
every dirty trick you could imagine
right they're trying every angle but
sometimes there's just such a compelling
advantage because there's been no new
injury for like 25 years right
they haven't faced the competitive
threat in their institutional lifetime
they really don't know how to behave in
response so you have on one hand yes
they'll try to do - Utley things and I
don't know what to say other than you
just kind of hope that enough of normal
democracy will flourish that you can
overcome that and not have critical ones
we'll see but on the other side you
don't usually not like when I was in
software investing as a primary focus
you don't usually find opportunities to
make a hundred fold or a thousand fold
cost advantage in a product but you do
in some of these areas cuz they
literally have faced no competitive
threat right so long they don't even
know what it's like to compete they take
like um the aerospace industry there's a
number of Chinese ministers who early on
when SpaceX when you give it a pricing
for the Falcon 9 they said well those
prices are not real we could not compete
at those price points even if we had all
Western technology like it's game over
and other US competitors said well we
basically have to shut down our product
lines and like imagine if some
competitive Oracle or Microsoft said
we're gonna come out with something like
oh yeah you're right we'd better stop
selling Windows right I'm just gonna not
do databases anymore because I have it
that's better I think no company
responds with we're shutting down our
entire product line and we were the
monopoly oh but we were the monopolist
prior yeah we were the thing right and
you know you know that and the only
caveat is they say that we're shutting
down our product lines but government
you got to have another company so give
us four billion dollars we'll build a
better one we can do it we can build and
give us four billion dollars like we
forgot to innovate for 25 years but no I
think it's a pile of money we'll start
right it's wild yeah I've never seen a
nugget um so one thing that we chatted a
little bit about before recording that I
wanted to ask you about is printed
organs and synthetic meat
hmmm so hopefully on the same dish
hopefully not in the same dish well you
never know
yeah the old nose-to-tail you know but
in this case you'd have to I suppose
imagine the exterior would be would be a
figment of your imagination in the case
of synthetic meat but can you where are
things currently with synthetic meat and
where will they be in the relatively
near term yeah it why is it for that
matter I think it's a great question so
um
and everything's grazes I think it's one
of the major tech themes or factors that
will affect a lot of people's lives over
the next 10 to 20 years and not
everyone's fully aware of it yet and
it's an inevitability so back when we
were talking about you know these
inevitable futures like all cars will be
electric all vehicles will be autonomous
this is one of those we will not
slaughter animals to get meat and though
the question is is that 50 years out is
that 500 years out but just like we
won't burn oil and gas 500 years out
there's like there's no way we would do
that 500 years out especially not in
small internal combustion engines that
we won't slaughter a cow to get a steak
and so the the insight occurs when you
realize first it's a much cheaper and
efficient way to grow the product you
need without the whole cow I get only
the hide you don't need the methane
production you don't need all that
inefficiency that was an artifact of
biological evolution you don't need the
land use the water used the energy use
you can cut all that somewhere between
10 and 100 x all of those factors which
by the way for the for the listeners who
don't know this about a third of all
usable land on earth is goes to meat
production so this is the grain that
gets fed the cows and pigs and chickens
and the land that those animals live on
so like a third of all usable land it's
astounding right it's like one of the
biggest water problems the biggest
methane gas which is one of the most
serious greenhouse gas problems it's
sort of on par with the whole
petrochemical economy or in other hands
if you could say I will get rid of oil
and gas forever or I'll get rid of meat
production you'd be better off getting
rid of meat production in the short term
in terms of greenhouse gases and the
environment so pretty a big big deal
okay
so why is this possible there are two
major branches of companies that are
trying to solve this one branch is to
replace meat with something that's not
meat and there's when I applaud those
efforts it's a little bit of a more of
an engineering challenge to get past the
consumer and each product has his own
engineer each and every product is
challenging you make the duck tastes
like duck make the chicken tastes like
chicken and
have it not just be like you know
sausages and hot dogs but actually
fillet if you want to take on the whole
quarter of the market so that will make
a meaningful impact and to be important
it's just gonna be slow moving because
of how hard it is to do each product and
to make it anything passable is
challenging extremely hard I mean
exactly I've tried a lot people been
trying every which way to do a veggie
burger there's big breakthroughs
recently by using heme and plant-based
heme just impossible that means you get
a veggie burger that bleeds basically
exactly exactly found a root of soy
plant that has a molecular cage that
holds an iron atom in the center that's
called a porphyrin that's the same
molecule kind of structure as we have in
hemoglobin that makes your blood red
that makes it you know turn colored when
it gets out of your body that makes your
right steak turn red that makes it taste
the way it does that makes it barbecue
the way it does so it Browns when you
bite all those things you put in a plant
right you can also put it by the way you
can make chicken the red meat it's kind
of fun but anyway um that's the
plant-based approached a lot of
engineering a lot of effort a lot of
money per product the other approach is
when we invested in called Memphis meats
and others like that says let's just
make steak
let's make chicken let's make any of
these products in like not just the
subject make the exact same thing but
don't grow it in a cow so it's more of a
change in the manufacturing method quite
simply right do you have the cow making
the steak or do you have it in a lab no
how do you make it in a lab well the the
team came from cardiology and other
medical backgrounds they have people
have done work in stem cell biology and
people have worked in you know the whole
synthetic biology area and it's pretty
straightforward to grow cells you take
stem cells you can induce them be
pluripotent or reduce them to be
immortal basically and you can just grow
an infinite number of these cells that
could become anything they could become
skeletal muscle they could become nerves
they could become skin and the way you
differentiate them into skeletal muscle
which is like our muscles in our arms is
you put them on a scaffold that causes
them to differentiate into that kind of
thing a scaffold that is it's an edible
gelatin like thing kind of you know it's
basically some other food products like
we have collagen and other stuff you
have this scaffold is things aerogel the
cells differentiate in the they merge
together into these long fibers just
like our muscle cells so what were
formerly discrete stanlon cells for
until one long multi multinucleated cell
it twitches it does everything like a
normal muscle it is a muscle cell of
that species where
the duck almost recently so it's duck
muscle and over time you can add the
irregularities of sinew and all this
right now it's like a perfect kind of
duck muscle you know the mouthfeel
everything it's just the same thing yeah
everything's a filet mignon exactly and
by the way in the future you can make it
healthier you can make it all and make
it three rich oils you could like tune
things but let's just start with the
simple don't confuse the market with not
it's it it's not turducken its turkey or
its dog and it's not a plan that's but
the imagine blending is like a simple
thing there's no reason you couldn't
infinite blending like blending a line
to make it just the right mouthfeel just
the right whatever so but in the near
term let's not jump ahead of ourselves
it's just a substitute and you can do
this in small like you know like a
Chinese shipping container and kind of
things you could put this near the point
of consumption you could have this in
urban areas so you're not shipping meat
all around the country let's growing the
steak you know sort of to order the end
cost point should be much much lower
instant to me this had one of those sort
of lightning bolt moments if this is the
inevitable future there's no technical
risk that says this couldn't happen
there isn't like we have to invent
something that hasn't there's a lot of
system engineering to optimize it the
feedstocks you know whatever that's it
building right reactor size it's gonna
take some engineering but it's not gonna
take breakthrough science he's the same
epiphany that when I first wrote in an
electric car when I first had an
autonomous ride but early on with the
Google ones you know the the old Prius
is that they had automated it's like
this is the future like you could you
just see it like a Clarion bell ringing
in your head and then a few implications
started the head like wow this will
transform the world in a lot of ways the
amount of land and resources and real
estate plays that relate to meat
production today not to mention Oh mad
cow disease influenza h1n1 all these
other things that we don't like those
collaterals right the climate is of the
food industry and we've gotten to that
um you can see how we'll get from here
to there that the buyers the largest
buyers of meat would absolutely like to
diversify their supply chain so they are
not vulnerable to in further or mad cow
or any other disruption to their supply
chain you see how they're gonna want to
feather that in so by the way Tyson and
Cardinal
two largest meat companies in America
invested in this company as well as in
the series a with us and but then I
realized something about myself I
realized for the first time something
where my future
self-will condemned my present self as
immoral yeah right so I know that 50
years from now once I'm eating the bacon
and steak that is not killed an animal
and its production will I be able to
visit a slaughterhouse for the first
time I won't do that today I like eating
meat so much that I refuse to go visit a
slaughterhouse in fact of the USDA meat
inspectors they ninety-nine percent of
them become vegetarian yeah they don't
start that way it's like if you see how
it's made you wouldn't need it and yet I
won't do that in and when I say moral I
think our humanities circle of empathy
expands over time you know first it was
you know family unit and the tribe in
the nation state then maybe global
citizens now I think the interspecies
and if you will empathy is inevitable
trajectory where I would welcome that
that would just be more thoughtful about
other sentient organisms and their
well-being that we just look right past
today it's kind of like being a slave
owner in America back in the 1700s the
economy depends on it I don't want to
ask questions about how those slave
ships I'm sure slave owners didn't visit
slave ships in the future I did we're
like oh my god we got to change this
right you just don't want to look and
when you had the once you have the
economic alternative that doesn't have
anything any compromises it's not like
oh it's not really bacon or it's not
really steak it's the same thing just no
animal died then you'll have the moral
shift I think profoundly we're what is
the current state I mean what products
do they have
there's young development because of the
costs side at scale soldier they're this
company's so so when I mentioned the
challenge of the plant-based substitutes
is engineering something that people
won't mistake I know that the taste as
good you know that's the key engineering
challenge here the whole thing's just
cost because you can make something
that's indistinguishable you just cost
too much right now right and there's
three vectors of making it cheaper too
or like total Kimmie's and one just
engineering the gimmies are just making
a bigger plant so if you brew beer if
you just have a 1 liter facility on your
desktop at home and you're amortize the
cost of you home to make one liter of
beer at a time it's gonna be expensive
leader a beer even if the formula is the
same as a huge production plan for sure
so scale the second is cheaper
feedstocks just feed it something other
than the very very expensive serum
losing out in R&D purposes to minimize
variables using pharmaceutical grade
inputs to the
so the feed the cells if you look what
do they feed them it's like a glucose
mixture with amino acids like a serum
like a blood serum it's kind of like
what you'd find in your blood to make
your blood cells live you know Wow
so it's a variety stuff that's used for
research purposes but there's no reason
it couldn't be the reason it doesn't
exist there's no market for or any a
food grade yeah uh you know plant-based
feedstocks that cells can grow off of um
and now we have a good reason to do that
yeah and then the third is just various
engineering optimizations on the cells
and the mixtures and and like what
combinations of cells do you want to try
to boost the fat content of each cell or
have separate you know muscle and fat do
you want to have it all be like one you
know one bite does already one I have
two different types that way yeah well I
mean few a few thoughts occurred to me
as you're describing this the first is
you know would this company would this
company ever utilize the the technology
to produce human tissue for regenerative
medicine or other purposes and then I
thought to myself wow you could also you
could become a moral cannibal if you
wanted like you can produce not that you
would want to produce human burgers and
eat them but you could ostensibly do
that but that was just more of a thought
I was like wow that's that's acquitted
well you can also a small donor to
revive and restore which is trying to
bring back the mammoths and it's yeah
species you could go back to have the
man with that's true that's true without
growing the mammoths yeah that's right
yeah yeah obey me this really gave me
yes the the friend burger just ran but
is that maybe a just a distraction I
don't know the technology well enough to
think of it from a from a from medical
human medical no dystrophy the Russian
in fact the first sort of clean meat or
alternative meat company that I came
across was using ironically the reverse
sequence which is it's spun out of a
company that was doing organs they've
printed bladders there's a kid I met
who's 18 years all these lived with a
grown bladder for many years now and in
but that was more like a 3d printer so
when you're growing a specific organ
that needs to be functional it's super
super important to get a lot of the
details right um a chunk of skeletal
muscle you know what you know if you
just take it from the center piece
versus the end with sinew you know
there's variation if you want to make it
funky
like a muscle right a connection to your
sinews and what have you that you're
making ground beef right from screaming
just the chunk of meat out of the middle
is just a chunk of meat so do you have
much bigger challenges with the printed
organs that lent itself naturally to a
3d printer kind of approach and it works
wonderfully for some organs they've been
growing kidneys and they're some of the
connective tissue stuff around
reconstructive surgery for the face and
what have you but it's slow it's also a
great example of personalized one the
one market like you want to go cells
that are compatible with your body so
that you know they'd source you your
stem cells to grow your organ for you
and it's it's kind of a different
approach and a number of ways
intuitively from what you want to
mass-produce for consumption where you
just who cares where the cow it could
all be the same cow clone that you're
growing the beef from where's every
human implant wants to be immune
compatible with what you've got so the
spin-out didn't make as much sense to me
to say well let's try to produce metric
tons of meat when using that 3d printer
like yeah any sense of a 3d printer yes
the I'm sure they're gonna figure out
some way to scale that up but I just
felt like to me there was a definite
technology risk there to just I couldn't
see the hand waving remit says why is
that gonna need a thousand times better
for sure it could but I don't see why it
has to you know it might not whereas
this other thing growing cells in a fat
inherently scales it's like just have a
bigger fat it's like yeah it's 3d to
start with it's not a 2d layering
there's something about that
manufacturing method I guess that's been
born out and things like brewing beer
and a variety of fermentation tasks
where you kind of understand how to
generate metric tons of stuff with the
fermentation process for people
listening like myself who were not
particularly being generous not
technically trained I wouldn't I'm
certainly not an engineer by any stretch
who want to make themselves more
scientifically literate are there any
books or resources or approaches that
you would recommend yeah there's two
things that jump to mind one is a
general-purpose overview of what's
important it's almost like a survey
level where if you're just a business
executive and you want to make sure
you're not blindsided by some
development that may be relevant but not
be a practitioner and then there could
be the question of well is there
something that like let's say you're a
former autonomous vehicle driver and now
you're looking for the next thing like
what might you want to study to
engage in the economy as a practitioner
and there are some areas that are more I
think easily approach to another so on
the so first in the overall survey I
think there are some writers who do a
good job bringing you with a sort of
overview mentality to like what's really
going on in the world people like Kevin
Kathy Kemp and Kelly and and maybe Matt
Ridley and maybe um and a few others
like this going back with Hostetler and
gödel Escher Bach there's there's been a
variety but I might highlight let's say
Kevin Kelly yeah because the single book
that's had the most influence on me in
my entire life is one of his earlier
ones called out of control you know
really started my lifelong fascination
of the biological metaphors and
technology everything from all that
stuff were talking about earlier about
cellular automata and and iterative
algorithms and evolution is itself an
iterative algorithm the power of
evolution the power of genetic
engineering all the stuff so he was
ahead of his time he wrote this book at
last century and it recently got
translated the Mandarin it's just in the
current day is one of those is probably
most popular books in China today even
though he wrote it decades ago um
because it's actually very relevant
today so that'd be a good starting point
I think it segues into the technology
that either as a practitioner or just
you can read about this if you just
direct yourself either simple google
searches or there's there's the
particular book I'd point out just to
learn about deep learning learning about
needle networks the the reason I say
that is I've never seen a greater demand
for a technology and a scarcity of
supply like the salaries being afforded
to engineers in this area are out of
control you know half a million dollars
for beginners who are some of the more
credible thinkers or practitioners who
talk publicly about deep learning let me
think
yeah I'm sure there's a good overview
that the place is well I know that
Coursera and some of these places are
trying and um Sebastian's runs Udacity
are trying to do deep learning courses
and such I haven't taken those I don't
know how good they I would imagine yeah
I've been some of the the very technical
people have given non-technical talks
whether whether it's at Google or
elsewhere I would imagine some of the
thinkers that might be in their day to
day work way too technical or
specialized I probably given
this is a tough one maybe for your show
notes I can try to come up with some
support my challenge i had is because i
started a PhD in this I didn't seek the
generic right and I've been reading once
I'm in the back of my no Michael is that
too technical and but I bet you I can
dig some up yeah sure and it may sound
self-serving but I've tried to give some
of those talks yeah and when I go to
conferences a number of times there's a
real dearth of other people doing that
same you know summarization but I would
say that the group out of Canada so
everything from Hinton to yoshua bengio
- Andrew Eng that was going back coming
back to the US in his case they are both
the leading edge of R&D and and such and
they give really good talks it's just
not all of them some of their deeply
technical some of them are overview so
I'll try to find that for you some
examples of toxic gave that are for the
average person
perfect perfect so that's that's what
we'll do that now I think I want to say
but if someone actually wants to get
into it is it's actually remarkably easy
to learn when I said it's weird the
labor market arbitrage is I don't think
it takes more than six to eight months
to become a really domain expert in this
and you don't have to be spectacularly
good at computer science before you the
background is it's just so different
from normal computer science you know
that arguably a new entrant has a great
opportunity to just learn how these
things are trained and forget about
normal computer side and you know I can
like I can say a few things in response
to that the first is to recommend people
check out so we talked about Tim urban a
little earlier and the tail end and so
on so I had Tim urban on this podcast
and I asked him how he got up to speed
on topics and he went through his exact
process called the for those people
interested if they just search Tim
Ferriss show Tim urban that'll pop right
up and he he spends about 20 minutes
talking about exactly this getting up to
speed which would be I think helpful for
a lot of folks and then in the show
notes at Tim Knobloch for such podcast
you can just find this and we'll have
some additional resources for people who
want to including myself
dig into this and learn learn more have
you ever given a kid this will be maybe
the last question or second the last
question have you ever given a
commencement speech Oh funny you should
ask
once for my high school and it was the
terrifying thing I've ever done like
like I love public speaking' I did the
bait back in high school and when I'm
speaking to an audience that's somewhat
similar to the audience's I've spoken to
before check if it's on subjects I've
spoken about before check this is my
power Ally I don't mind that oh my god
trying to be relevant to a bunch of 18
year olds Wow that was tough as back in
Dallas yeah but I did that few years
back what did you talk what did you talk
about what did and maybe if if its broad
what did people respond most strongly to
of what you told them oh I can actually
give you show notes I managed to keep a
copy and someone even translated it into
Spanish oh yeah great so I'm trying read
what it was I was trying to well here it
was the advice I got that really helped
was think about when you were their age
and the more time I spend thinking about
what life was like with me for me as a
senior XO I went to that same school it
all sort of clicked into place the what
do I want to do with my life what's
going on in the world and sort of
weaving what I was learning for much
capital and all the amazing
entrepreneurs that I was seeing to
convey to them like why you aren't
entering the most exciting period in
human history and I shared a little bit
about things we spoke about on this
podcast around you know things were on a
synthetic biology things going on in AI
and what have you each of these areas is
so rich with opportunity and I gave them
some general advice about just thinking
about your career as a pursuit of
passion thinking about what you're
uniquely good at that no one else in
your random walk through life may have
done and to keep that in mind as you
hopefully infuse with a bit of technical
open-mindedness and creativity in
childlike mind in exploration of what
you want to do that they're just like
it's no better time to be entering the
world and trying to make a difference I
tried to encourage them a lot to think
entrepreneurially to think about being
change agents for the world that
everything that history books were
written about is some new entrant
entering a field they didn't know much
about prior and encouraging them that
this is what increasingly defines the
world we live in
even one question is somebody posed to
me when I was considering the question
or considering unique strengths I was
like I don't know if I have any unique
strengths I do a lot of things kind of
well but I'm not sure yet maybe that's
it maybe it's the pattern magic across
those and the question that they asked
me was
what are you what do you find easy
that's something that a lot of your
friends find hard and I was like huh and
that actually ended up being very
helpful question for somewhat indirectly
landing on the strengths because I had a
lot of trouble with that
so maybe folks find that five is
question that helpful yeah there
everyone does have some acid element to
that question and they also have
something they've done that back to that
early question when I was in any venture
capital well how am I differ from every
other venture capitalists who's you know
trying to do this job there's something
about your personal background it could
be a language skill it could be wow you
had to take care of an aging grandmother
in your youth and you see you have a
sympathy and empathy for what the age
are going through that others lack like
that actually could be superhero
strength if you want to be an
entrepreneur for this aging demographic
of baby boomers not everyone in fact
very few entrepreneurs think about the
agent for example and I think it could
and your unique strengths can also be an
unusual combination of two strengths
right I've heard Marc Andreessen talk
about layering public speaking on top of
anything else and separating yourself
Warren Buffett would say something very
similar Scott Adams of Dilbert famous
talked about this let's say you have an
unusual combination right so right maybe
you have a double D degree and then you
have an MBA that's right and then they
know how to clean you now to debate you
don't have to be the best of the world
at any of those things there's a lot of
wisdom there because it's that pairing
that anyway that's I think why most
scientific breakthroughs are
interdisciplinary there are someone
outside of the field of chemistry
working with someone maybe in the field
to come with a breakthrough not someone
at the core of again an academic
discipline and this is why universities
are such areas of foment of innovation
is because they have all the disciplines
in the one physical campus but if you
just had a chemistry department or just
a chemistry college it wouldn't make
world breaking changes right the people
who figured out the structure of DNA
we're like an ornithologist and a
physicist not chemists right yeah
crystallographers well actually rosalind
parks needs to get credit there's got a
shout out to her so she's the
traditionalist in that regard but more
and more people think about Elon not
domain expert entering a new domain it's
the cross-pollination right being let's
say software design modalities to the
aerospace industry or our user Griffey
into personal computers exactly and so
that pairing I think harkens back to one
other thought that might bring this
whole thing full circle
every great idea is a recombination of
prior ideas this is a a really powerful
and simple idea that was popularized in
three different books at the same time
which i think is meta ironic that their
argument at the same time as every good
idea happens around the same time and
the reason that's interesting is you can
think in history Edison and Tesla and
Marconi is like the time was right given
the breakthroughs that had just have an
electricity magnetism to think about AC
induction motors and radio and
everything else got invented by all the
same people are all within months of
each other today writ large we have many
more ideas we have the internet allowing
us to cross-pollinate ideas like never
before these two things that are unique
that you pollinate together the
calligraphy and the you know computer
design for jobs or what have you the
number of possible pairings is growing
combinatorially and that's why we have
accelerating change technology that's
why Moore's law exists over such a long
time frame it's not because of the
semiconductor industry it's because the
number of idea pairings is growing is it
to the N factor
it's called reads law with the number of
ideas on the planet and once you break
down the barriers between formerly
discrete academic disciplines and strip
all that vernacular away of their
independent ways of communicating with
each other that are so isolating and you
see the common patterns like weeds and
that's just like a information theory I
saw there and the microbial design
fronts like then that same problems in
you know all these rich array of new
ideas is a sort of meta reason where you
can't really quantify how strong us
would be it will probably see more
innovation ever before and it's not just
because we all will see more innovation
than ever before it's because this
combinatorial explosion of idea pairings
is happening globally and oh by the way
it's about to explode when the next four
billion people come online we go from
two to six billion people online because
of satellite broadband that SpaceX and
others are developing that's all coming
in the next five years like holy [ __ ]
we're gonna have a just explosion idea
possibilities and innovation across the
planet exciting time to be alive
exactly especially when you have quantum
computers accessing potentially parallel
universes that's right where does it end
it doesn't well Steve thank you so much
for taking the time this was really fun
and it's meandering as is the path I
forged hopefully you had fun as well and
to be continued hopefully we have we
have many more conversations and I've so
many more questions for you so another
tip for another time but
where can people find you online to say
hello see what you're up to
sure so on Facebook I'm just username
Jurvetson and Flickr user named rivets
and muslins that's the ones I like most
of my old writings are like the old
stuff my my 2004 is mostly on Flickr and
then my social network addiction du jour
is Facebook and what is next for you
what's next so I'm gonna start a new
venture fund some point this year I
haven't picked the name yet but I'm
bouncing some ideas around to focus
entirely on purpose driven businesses
with really long time frames where we
never sell a share at least I don't and
we will be investing in the kinds of
things we talked about today companies
that hopefully history books will be
written about companies whose founders
have a purpose greater than their own
life on this planet and a purpose
greater than certainly making a quick
buck and there are more opportunities
and more industry sectors than I've ever
seen like what button laws have you seen
the 90s is like software semiconductors
and life sciences that was it but I
never imagined it invest and just write
just balls and ghazal being the the
pinnacle or the nadir of intellectual
curiosity but now it's just a
flourishing coral reef of innovation
everywhere and incredibly interesting
tiny of esting startups well can't wait
to see you do next
thank you and to everybody listening
there will be plenty of links and the
show notes including the things we
promised resources to deep learning and
much more you can check that out at tim
dot blog forward slash podcast and as
always thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun
weekend and five bullet Friday's a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I committed to making
sleep a top priority trying to fix onset
insomnia or continuing to fix that depth
of sleep quality of sleep I tracked a
lot I tested a lot and I revisited
really everything from daily routine to
the surfaces I slept on playing with a
chili pad whatever and when I moved to
Austin I got all new beds including
mattresses from helix working with the
world's leading sleep expert certainly
some of them helix sleep developed
mattresses personalized to your
preferences and sleep style to make sure
that you can have the best sleep
possible without costing thousands upon
thousands of dollars helix sleep has
recently added a new layer and
customized sleep with the helix pillow
the all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of a sleep position or body
type or if you're shifty type like me I
move around quite a bit when I sleep
just take their simple two to
three-minute sleep quiz to get started
and that will help ensure that they can
build a mattress or pillow that you will
love the mattress
whatever this bespoke mattress is that
you arrive at will get to you within a
week and the shipping is completely free
you can try the mattress for 100 nights
and if you're not completely happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund
tested that refund policy because I test
all of these sponsors and kick the tires
a lot and tested it and they came
through on making sure that we got
ultimately the right mattress for my
body type to personalize your sleep
experience visit helix sleep comm
forward slash Tim and you'll receive up
to $125 off your mattress order that's
helix sleep atli ex sleep comm forward
slash Tim with $125 off your order this
episode is brought to you by 4 Sigma
deck
you might remember 4 sig Matic for their
mushroom coffee which was created by
those clever Finnish founders and when I
first mentioned that coffee on this
podcast the products sold out in less
than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum the new product and that is
their reishi mushroom elixir to help me
end my day to get to sleep as you guys
may know longtime listeners at least I
struggled with insomnia for decades
I will largely fix that but still
shutting off my monkey brain has never
been easy it still isn't easy very often
and I found reishi which have been
fascinated by for a few years now has
been very very effective and calming
their old formula however before sig
Mattox old formula included stevia and I
like to avoid sweeteners all sweeteners
for a host of reasons and I then just
ping them and asked hey guys I would
love to experiment with this and maybe
actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if too much of a headache
don't worry and they are always game for
experimentation and so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily
here's some recommended copy that they
put in the read so I'm gonna read it not
give you my take quote a warning for
those in the experimental mindset reishi
is strong and bitter in parentheses like
any great medicine so if the bitterness
is too much I recommend trying it with
honey and or nut milk such as almond
milk and quote so I'm gonna say no you
should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter and
maybe should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
youngins when they say well that looks
sugar cool which means you're not able
to eat bitterness bitter is in many
cases an indication of things that help
the liver detoxification and so on not
saying that's the case here but I've
tested this ratio later on and family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and know don't put it honey or nut milk
or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think all
right if you like poo air that kind of
stuff that type of tea you're gonna dig
it so just try it okay back to then my
read if you'd like to naturally improve
your sleep both on set and quality I
think naturally you might just enjoy
this ratio lecture without any
sweeteners it has organic reishi extract
organic field mint extract organic
rosehips extract organic Tulsi extract
and that's it no fancy stuff no
artificial whatchamacallit anything so
check it out go to for stigmatic comport
size Ferriss and get 20% off this
special batch not enough they're gonna
be making much more of this since it was
made specifically for you guys so do me
a favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI g ma t IC comm
forward slash ferrous fe r RI SS and get
20% off the special batch and you must
use the code at Ferris to receive your
discount FB
Riss so again go to four sig Metacom
four slash Paris and then use code
Ferris for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
you
you
you